all right and we are live
the last word with lor cognito and
ebatis fresh
off that friday evening campfire
very family-oriented show i feel you
what's going on man
uh well we've got story stuff to talk
about sandbox things we've also got
lawsuits and other fun stuff crazy
topics today but we got
two awesome gentlemen joining us on the
podcast tonight so i want to pass it
back to you so you can bring one of
these gentlemen in
dropping his face into the world at
least that i know for the first time
let's see it you gotta drop them in
first i got the other one
that's how you wrote it that's how we
did it that's how you wrote it okay
well this is planned out really really
well so that's
coordination it's totally fine
coordination yeah this is this is called
uh calling an audible
there you go so i'd like to welcome a
gentleman who has been gaming
near uh since nearly birth he has a
special place for nintendo games
as they were key to his childhood and
even has an autographed copy of mario
kart double dash to prove it
he loves his love of gaming and tech has
continued into his adult life
and his i.t skills have taken him from
geek squad all the way to doing
freelance work for the gaming mecca
ign this man takes hardcore and
completionist to a whole new level
and a triumph score in destiny 2 that's
so high he has things he's done that
even he
isn't proud of his knowledge of this
game is top tier and there isn't
anything he can't accomplish with a
controller in his hand
so 129 7735 points later
let's welcome sir teasing teddy to the
campfire
thank you for having me as always this
is always fun and a pleasure
nice glass amazing too glad to have you
by the already no
i i like the score we got the triumphs
you did your research
i respect it and of course we have a
lord who is not only fair
family to the game fight of the last
word but is also one of the most
supportive and humble members
in our entire destiny community whether
it be his passion takes on the law
overall commitment to pvp and an
absolute talent for exploring the
intricacies
of the pve sandbox
introducing the created host of the
wilhelm scream youtube and twitch
channels the lord of efficient farming
and glitches yet still refuses to
promote his own videos
live from new york state and making his
return
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord wilhelm scream how you doing
sir
i'm doing great i have been so waiting
for that intro
i've been dreaming about that intro
before the show that i was like i felt
bad because i think the times you have
on
i never gave you an official intro we
kind of had like some impromptu stuff
and then you came early
so i'm like we gotta roll out the red
carpet for awesome screen yeah i do it
scream i ain't doing course
it was the it was the early year i think
it was still flashpoint i don't think
i think yeah pretty sure i was there at
the inception of the idea for
last word but um i don't think i was
actually on
since the last word so it's been a good
bit of time but
i love being here i love being back
thank you for the intro i'm doing good
and just happy to be here very excited
very appreciative brother appreciate it
for the long overdue man
you know how have you been sir what's up
what's going on
what happened soon i'm
good i'm just warning y'all at 9pm
eastern i might be slightly
distracted but i'll still be here this
man is a multi-tasker at its best
in here making things happen shout out
to xbox fanfest baby big money big money
no whammies no wins if you understand no
whammies
put what follows that in chat by the way
if you understand and then we'll know
how old you are
let me again let's go man i'm good man a
lot of stuff going on and
oh that's there's a lot to talk about i
know you did a video right there's a lot
going on i literally did three videos in
24 hours
wow i did i literally broke up the twab
into two things because i recorded part
live on stream and then i'm like
it was like i was asking chat and i was
like should this be two and they're like
two two two i'm like okay okay we're
making another video and did the next
topic and then we did zur
then this one's gonna go up so we're
gonna have like four videos on my
channel probably too many for youtube to
know what to do with so
if you guys do watch them thank you in
advance but we covered a lot of topics
out there
um yeah and we're in this weird downtime
because i want i tweeted to the group dm
that we've got out there
and people are doing speed runs to zur
yo that's where we're at in destiny
right now
that's what people are doing sweatsicle
has been doing that for like the last
three weeks i think he started a trend i
don't know if he's cracking me up it was
like fall out i even saw sweats and he
was doing it and he was like he got to
this guy
he's like had like the fist pump
everything
oh it's ridiculous so that being said
how much have you guys been playing
destiny
in the past month or two or anything of
that nature like how long how much of
you guys been playing destiny recently
and this isn't to call you out this is
honestly just the state of where we're
at
yeah so i would start with teddy
i played yesterday for the first time
since the first day of festival lost
which i played the entire first day uh
and then before that i hadn't played
until the end of
solstice of heroes i am in a place where
i don't want to play this game
shout out to teddy there's not a lot to
do
i mean the intro lives up to it max
triumph score he's literally
literally actually done it all that's
not figurative that's
um and yeah there's not much left for
you right now in the waiting time what
about you scream how much have you been
you've been finding weird funky glitches
trying to break the game before they fix
it all
i'm trying to but i think they've i've
either found them all currently
or they're just they've gotten rid of
any of the fun stuff like there's some
little things here and there there's
always like
that might be a thing we bring up later
but we'll get there
oh yeah but you know it's like
like bounty hoarding doesn't really seem
to be like it's gonna like that would be
what you were doing right now
so it would be like um trying to figure
out the most efficient way to farm out
all the bounties but
there's no point in doing it so it's
like even farming out certain gear
you know it's like you have everything
like you can go to the the recaster and
you can
turn in a whole bunch of stuff but if
you don't have it all by now
then like i mean you can go do that
certainly but it doesn't really give me
a lot
to do necessarily so i've been playing
i play every week ever usually i reset
every tuesday i'll get on for like a
couple hours just decide to see like
all right did they what's you know
what's the
the flash point this week even though i
don't think they call it the flash point
anymore but what the what's the plan
called this week and
yeah yeah and like the planets are still
the flash point that's actually still
there
right okay it's still flash point all
right so what's the flash point
what's the nightfall or deal for the
week to see if there's like
a good time if it's a good time to run
uh
you know like uh 1100 and if there's an
exploit for it
i'll i'll do something on that but i've
covered like all of them already at this
point and
nobody wants to do anything other than
lake of shadows anymore
so it's like if it's not like a shadow
it's a double reward nobody cares
facts i get disappointed when i don't
see i mean
right that just kind of goes to show
where the state of the
nightfalls are at too and like what
people are looking for
probably some of the worst stuff though
is i see people grinding nightfalls and
they're like
lost another 10 uh 10 what i can't even
remember it's been so long since i've
actually gone for the ascendant shards
shards yeah i was like i saw 10 i got
kicked in shards out of my postmaster
and just like i want to cry because
i know that takes a little while to
grind at least
i have been juggling 18 out of 21
postmaster slots
for six months wow and nothing has gone
nothing's gotten pushed out it's all
exotics shards prisons this man does
one activity kills nothing goes back to
the tower
on a consistent basis div dim is very
helpful damn
yes indeed respect it respect you
everything that golf ball farming them
shards band like
that's pretty much i think for me same
boat like just trying to be
efficient as we prep you know as we get
closer
just making sure the rolls are tight
making sure i got all different variants
you know what i'm saying of different
stuff i've been hitting every cast up a
little bit
but yeah same same deal man same deal
just just not
much but um oh well now actually i've
been starting to do my um
you know getting in the raid farms and
stuff like that and cleaning up and
teddy would notice we had a great
conversation
recently uh about what's going away
catalyst-wise and
a good discussion on you know if i
you know if you didn't complete or
whisper of the worms catalyst
you know you couldn't start it this week
right right but like
is it gonna be a situation for people
like i think shout out to addict like
he's in a situation or
where they might not have enough time to
complete certain ones like
he has sleep or similar catalyst i'm
jealous but it's so many steps
so it's just like what's gonna happen
and it was a good discussion being teddy
highway it's like
is it going to be removed the catalyst
is going to be removed from
from the gun because it's incomplete you
know that kind of thing so it just it
was kind of curious so
finishing up that kind of stuff yeah i
was like for me i'll log in on tuesday
i'll do my
if i can find a group that's doing
escalation protocol get my world line
catalyst i'm
60 there outbreak i've got a buddy
manodestra he's like we're going to have
him on the podcast at some point later
on
he can do that thing in his sleep mana
exactly yeah he's working on trying to
get a thousand whatever
a thousand runs through zero hours his
goal before
beyond light and he's at like 900 i
think
wow so he's carried a bunch of people
he's he will just like literally do it
while he's like watching a show and he's
got
like a glitch where he can skip part of
it so he's got plain like the other
people as long as you kill the beginning
enemies
yeah he's like boss is dead and there's
like five minutes left and usually like
go on there's a barrier yep through the
wall yeah watch me stream it it's crazy
that he goes through
so that one and then outbreak so those
are my two catalysts but outside
like i'm not going for sleeper i'm not
going for telesto
i haven't i haven't really been to ben
out of shape not having the catalyst up
to this point
i'm not gonna like you know break myself
to try and go after like raid grinds
over and over because you can only do
those
you can't even like go after those like
the exotics anyway you get a chip one
chance a week and if you don't get it
and i'm like
i'm not that worried about it yeah yeah
i mean
again teddy we had that discussion right
we were just saying how you know we just
feel it's a little messed up that
you know a lot of those some of those
catalysts require rng or very time gated
activities
and it's just like one would have
thought they would have either blessed
the rng a bit
or the drop rate on those specific
rewards and uh
teddy has some theories so
for for the final stretch of the season
they made it so that raids
drop um you can do them over and over
repeatable basically
but for whatever reason the catalyst
specifically
the drop it's a one week lockout so you
only get one chance
the initial time you do it that sounds
like it's pretty
intentional to me like that's not
something that you like overlook and
you're like oh
whoops we accidentally didn't you know
change the one to a zero on this
are you implying engagement
encouragement
pretty much i mean that's just that's
that's what it boils down to
you want them to be raiding as much as
you can be for this last little bit
they don't they don't ever tell us these
things so
they really just go up you know it's
just what i my opinion i gotta make that
very clear because people will flame me
yes yeah but
no i mean that's what it is it has i
mean
there are certain times where like hey
there was an oops he made in destiny and
then there's other times you're like i
know that wasn't an accident and that's
one of those where you're like
you intentionally made these things you
said hey exotics
raid loot you can do it over and over
and over certain that's what shawn turn
that switch on
exotics leave that one off like they're
going down the line fixing these things
so you can do it and they intentionally
made the decision to be like
oh you can't farm catalyst you have to
do you know sparrow runs and scourge for
these mods that don't even matter by the
way
those aren't really going to matter
they're all going away they're getting
depreciated and all that
stuff and i know people had granted
those for a while and they're like well
yes i can stop which is a good thing
and that's kind of one of those things i
wanted to ask you guys about and we said
that a little bit in chat
but it's just like the timing of their
choice of when to tell us some
information
it's always kind of interesting to me at
least like we finally were like three
weeks out now
and like the hoarding the bounty thing
kind of was covered but even there's
like some people like
can we have like some clarity and then
you know like people ha
i've been hearing people even like
certain discords and stuff like they're
like
hey we're doing scores runs again and
again and again and then they finally
are like yeah we're not using those mods
and it's always those
i think teddy you might have actually
had a pretty good theory on it
um just you know the same thing almost
to try and give engagement during this
downtime because if they said they're
not there people are gonna stop playing
but on the other side how does that come
across to your base when you're like hey
i've been crying in this thing it's
gonna be fallen
three weeks before the end of the season
yeah that's not gonna work you're like
i'm sorry
what i've been doing this how much for
and that's just oh it's
i understand why but also it's like
respecting your player base
for their time that they put in for
something that's not gonna matter when
they typically expect like most of the
mods that we've earned so
far continue to add on into the game we
haven't really lost anything besides
what's been attached to the artifact
and now the fact that you've got mods
that are attached to all these raids
work everywhere taken's the only one the
others are gone and these things have
been in the game for
a couple years now so it's like it's
been a decent thing it was thought of
something to grind for
so i was curious if you guys had any
thoughts on that or if it was just me
um oh teddy scream go ahead go ahead
scream i'll let teddy go here
okay um they're too nice they
they seemingly always do this or most
the time where
they tend to announce the changes that
will affect the next season or dlc
right before the dlc happens and
i feel like some of them not all of them
they probably know pretty far in advance
but they just don't want to tell us
um i have nothing to substantiate that
other than like intuition and just kind
of the way they communicate
things to us but it
kind of irks me when it's like all right
one week we're like all right armaments
don't matter anymore but you know you
grinded for them this entire season
because you thought they were gonna work
and just to like preface this ahead of
uh on the side
i think getting rid of armaments or
deprecating them is a good thing
uh they definitely they only needed to
go it just sucks that they told us
now instead of four months ago right
when it comes to like uh
a blanket here the like the the grind
stuff like to
to basically make us you know or not
make us but
incentivize us to go play the raid it's
like hey we brought back these raids and
you can you can grind them indefinitely
and loot drops but guess what we're
changing the armor
so you gotta basically those are
invalidated now again
and it kind of irks me the wrong way
because it's like
you essentially lied to me like like you
kind of were like do this thing
you're gonna be rewarded later for it
but wait no we changed our mind here
um and i get it i'm sure like
things are just in flux for them when
they when they're making this stuff and
so maybe they don't even know the answer
to it right
but like like the bounty stuff for
example they had to have known that
in advance because this is what the the
fourth year that we've been doing this
now where it's like stacked your
bounties
yep um so it's just stuff like that that
i mean you guys know this i've talked
about this before like it just bothers
me but
i'm still going to play the game so
mm-hmm he's got a triumph score he's
definitely going to play yeah
i'm locked in for life that's that's the
problem
they got us any thoughts on all this
controversial timing of messaging
not really i'm just making that up but
you know
um i mean it was sort of expected i i
like teddy was saying um the bounty
thing
yeah that one that's the one that really
surprised me because it was sort of like
i i would always assume that they were
going to do this eventually
because it was such a shortcut once the
new season started and i always was
i always just felt like that was one of
those things that they didn't
really know how to control it like they
wanted people to play so they wanted
people to
hoard bounties because they don't want
the end of the season to go out with
like a whimper
they want people like ramped up for the
next season
but they couldn't figure out how to do
that while have
um you know not cheat the next season
so they were trying to like play this
balancing act forever and i just didn't
know when
it would finally like the shoe would
finally drop you know
um but i mean it makes sense
i'm not really upset with it it's more
like i just don't
really know what to do i guess i can
most of my time lately if i'm in the
game uh
has been spent just trying to get any
exotics that i didn't get not even
worrying about the catalyst because
there's so many that i'm just like
it's not even realistic for me to really
think about them i just want the weapon
so that i can you know use it for for
something else later if i want to do
some exploits so really everything that
i've been doing has sort of
been from a content creator's
perspective like not
rea i don't even really remember i think
the last time
i actually was just playing straight
like just just
get something that i wanted to and i
just was spending the time
just to play it was when we were farming
out the anarchy
which was like what like i was thinking
about run yeah that was a fun one yeah
it was we did a lot of runs
but like shout out to you that was that
was like the last time we did
it or that was like the last time i was
like just playing just because i wanted
to get something everything since then
has really just been to uh sort of recap
what's going on that week and and you
know put out some
stuff for people if they're looking for
that like last little bit of like
really like focused end game content
like those guys who are
who want that 1100 nightfall or deal
done
and they want them all you know they
want that uh seal
so other than that i'm not really upset
by it so much as
i hope that when they do this later on
that they can figure out a better way to
do it because it's blatantly obvious
they just didn't tell us
i don't think it's i mean i don't think
it's really
i don't think they're fooling anybody at
least anybody who's played for more than
i don't know six months they don't
really know how to do this properly so
they just didn't tell us yeah
shout out shout out to cat daddy to chat
he was you said good times you talk
about
those anarchy runs thank you yeah again
yo again scream shout out to you because
to be honest you man i
i gave up on anna i was like i'm never
gonna get that i was i just literally
and it was just screaming the crew they
like yo did she the clan's in here man
get in here
we're doing runs and yeah dude like we
just farmed it i think what was the
thing i think what has happened is only
a couple people were getting it and then
i was i think i said someone else opened
the chest first and then
maybe the other people who haven't got
it could get it right and it worked out
that time
it was kind of funny yeah
shout out to cat daddy because he was
actually the guy who had the checkpoint
he was the one who ringed me up he's
like yo i got the checkpoint and i'm
like
okay we're just doing it we're going for
it and then like people just kept
joining in
joining in attic like like everywhere
like everybody literally it was like
from the phone it was like an assembly
line of everybody in the clan who didn't
have anarchy
and it was like yo let me get
i said bro i just got anarchy like i've
never thought i was gonna get that
so yeah shout out to you guys that was a
fun run shout out to send us to the clan
good good time always good to have
screen sinister
you got your name on my anarchy and your
names on my xenophage
nice oh yeah this is well the xenophage
i take full credit for that one
i own all progress for everybody in the
world on that weapon
for it oh you're the best for that bro
and i i went kicking this guy i was like
i don't want to do that guns trash this
is pretty
though baby
oh yeah i was like i mean that's that's
kind of where the state of destiny has
been
for seems like all of us is like dot in
the final eyes
of whatever the season has left and
mostly for the year
of stuff that you might be missing some
of us had a lot of stuff done some of us
were just going for
triumph score some of us had to hit a
catalyst here there it's been quiet
um i don't know if we'll do a full
season review right now or anything but
generally
one of the big things that started
dropping was late last week early this
week is the fact that there have been
websites starting to crumble under the
pressure of the uh ban hammer
which has been wonderful i was gonna say
incognito as you're a pvp guy
and anybody who does trials especially i
want to pass it to you first as you
like when you started seeing like
especially the uh
perfection one start to fall like what
you think
like is is this what you've been waiting
for is this like
what do you think it's not you know it's
it's going in the right direction
it's going in the right direction i felt
that off shout out to ask the cross
brother
i saw the tweet and i was like what's he
like is that that's one of my pvp
go-to's and i'm just like what's he
getting all excited about
stop looking and i'm like ah they're
hitting up the you know the avatar war
hack sites you're getting cease and
desist
so i'm like wow okay we're taking action
legally
this is a good thing you know what i'm
saying now in the grand scope of things
is it
stopping every single hack no but it's
good to see
you know they are taking steps it's
going in the right direction you know
it's still we still got a long way to go
though you know i said because
you know teddy can attest you know we've
been in those trials run those pvp runs
and
you just you just get it's at the point
now where
you're afraid to give someone credit for
good play
because you're like i want to say that
was a great snipe you did
i want to say you outplayed me but then
there's a part of me where i look at
your stats and i look at you thinking
i'm like ah
yeah so it's always questionable like
like most of the time it's probably not
a cheater but you always have that down
in your mind where you're like
oh it could be and then you look at the
stats and you're kind of like uh
you know so constantly that's the
ultimate go
to excuse me yes as long as an excuse
exists
and it's the thing that drives you crazy
because you'll always get frustrated
because as soon as you die
you have that excuse in the back of your
mind and you just go cheater
that's it it's over thanks and then you
just
you know throw something and and leave
no shoe i mean look at the other
dangerous household you got their screen
it is yeah man the other day is just one
of those things where you're just like
okay
you know i like that actions being taken
let's see how far they continue to ramp
this up we know
as we're going to get into the 12
there's going to be a lot of you know
new
trials things that's happening so you
know they're not running away from pvp
and these things got to be addressed so
i also want to see how the relationship
with steam in on pc is going to work
with these type of uh moves so step in
the right direction but i was definitely
at least happy to see
that type of action taken yeah i mean me
too it was nice to see some people like
is this gonna instantly fix it
no some people are saying hey the
software still works for another 30 days
the one big thing i saw we have to
completely re-down
download beyond light that's a fresh
install a new patch that's the point
where
did you not know that screen i saw that
expression
you're gonna have to completely
re-download the client for
pretty much everything so especially if
you're on playstation 4
and you got that you know copy time
you're going to want to make sure you
plan ahead the servers are going down at
like 9 p.m the night before for at least
my time something like that
so you're going to have some time but
make sure if you're going to work and
you come home
do it in the morning do it the night
before do it at midnight whenever you
can like do it before you go to work so
at least you come home and it's done
because that is definitely going to take
some time but i'm honestly wondering if
that will help too a brand new
version comes out that nobody's got like
time to kind of dig into as much and
maybe they make some changes in there
they're doing the
they're switching up something with the
clients where it's like more physics
based versus something i can't remember
all the terminology i know some of you
guys may know what i'm talking about
they're making a change there on how
like the world sees as opposed to
this many groups of this enemy are live
now it's gonna know where they are and
if they can do a couple more things
to understand like hey you just fired
seven thousand times in one second
respawned four times
yeah you probably need to go like if
they can actually finally have something
that reads that type of stuff
maybe we'll be in a better place but
we'll just have to see
i hope things keep getting better
because as you said cognito when we get
to uh
the last part of the twab we have some
incentive that if you people are going
to want to cheat
now there's more incentive than ever but
we will get to that a little bit later
but in the middle of the week we also
got story oh yeah
we got a lot of people who played a lot
of pieces of this game we've got a spin
foil hat expert down
here he's got a tank top and a spin foil
hat but he's looking good either way
uh sounds great but we
try you know i try but we got a trailer
and
i gotta take i gotta pass it you scream
first when you watch this trailer
just first thoughts as soon as you
watched it what's what's your
your theories your thoughts would you
feel about it i watched it like four
times but
i want to get yours first because i'm
very curious what you've been thinking
i i'm sort of
you know like you know i have a theory
and i'm hanging on to it
exactly uh i you know and
i gotta be honest i didn't really know
how i could connect and maybe i missed
something and maybe you could point out
maybe there's
one major thing that i missed connect
this particular sort of enemy
it seems like a precursor enemy um
and you know it doesn't not
fit in to my theory but i don't think
it's like
it's not that like uh it's not that like
real you know specific
thing that i thought would tie it all
together there was actually something
else that um if you wouldn't mind me
just so
foreign
this is a theory that actually i just um
sort of ascribed to it was actually um
the guy who came up with is a buddy of
mine big shout out to my buddy reaper
geiber he's been gaming forever and he's
a huge lord dude he loves
destiny lore and halo lore he'll he'll
know any lore even if he doesn't play
the game he gets into the loot
so his theory to summarize into
one sentence is that maharasov is
sabathun
and that the dreaming city
was actually created through
the adoption of a vex mind that
or oryx yes the taken king gave to
savathun
as like a present to uh
that was it was initially designed the
vex mine was actually designed to defeat
the hive but was defeated and then was
given
to savathun as a gift and she used it
with the ability and it has the ability
i think to create singularities
to create the dreaming city as a way to
subvert
the sword logic so that's why the
dreaming city always is on a three-week
pattern
is we need to continually consume either
we beat the raid
and it consumes that way or we get
defeated and it consumes that way
but essentially it puts it on a loop
allowing her to
not have to constantly live this like
life of consumption
essentially but there was something in
and everything as far as like what we
are going to be getting
definitely kind of holds into that right
um as far as expansions are concerned
in the trailer i didn't necessarily pick
out one specific thing that was
directly related to that but um
the involvement of the drifter
is heavily like tied to that because
essentially gambit is the same thing
it's like
a a consumption loop right and
there was another thing in the um
uh means to an end quest this past week
the last one that we got
yeah where we we see nakris
and there's that cut scene and there's
the dialogue where
i i can't remember who asked the
question but one of the characters it
might be the goat your ghost
asks why savathun is interested in
nakras
um and they make a reference to him
being a necromancer and
figuring out a way to
like i can't remember exactly the word
that they were using
but essentially use a pattern of
destruction that
again subverts sword logic through a
loop
they may i think they actually mention
the word a loop and then they ask
why would she be interested in him and i
think it's because
she was trying to figure out the same
thing and this was just another person
who did the same thing and that's also
why
the drifter is involved and
i think ultimately it'll just that's
that's where it will go
but again because what is wrong
[Laughter]
with the whole idea of like when the oh
sorry and then the awoken were
formed in a black hole and like
marasov's crew were actually humans that
fell
into a black hole and the singularities
that create are created by the vex
are essentially black holes so it's like
and i
actually think that's kind of what the
darkness is it's
well the darkness is kind of like the
worms that control the hive essentially
or
it infected the proto-hive at least
that's in my mind and i think
what we're facing in the pyramid ships
are like that
joining of that vex mind that was
that was created to defeat the hive
controlled by the hive and that's why
you get this like so let me ask you a
quick question
with this beyond life story reveal
trailer
based on what you've seen you know first
of all your excitement level for it
number one and then two
uh it's you know based on what you've
seen like do you feel
any anything with your theory was
shaking or you still think things can
still consistently fall
for where you're going but i think it
was i think it was reinforced actually
i think that i mean everything that i've
seen has
though there's stuff that isn't you know
like they reveal something and it's not
necessarily directly
pointing to that there's nothing that
points away from that
there's just you know like everything
we're going to have arcs to this that
ultimately reveal
something else it doesn't mean that the
arc from the
you know the standpoint of like this
this is the new enemy
we have to defeat them okay that's all
we need to really know right now
right where what happens at the end of
that that that will probably play into
the overarching story but just based off
of what
expansions are coming and sort of the
the characters involved moreover
um that seems to really point to it and
all these little things like that
thing with nocris that really like
i don't know that really backed it up
for me i wish i knew exactly what they
said in the cutscene
but it was essentially saying that this
person inaccuracy had figured out a way
to i think they said subvert the worms
i think that's what they said not fair
enough
teddy man new story trailer
what's going on man how are you feeling
about it it's
i mean it's a story trailer like i'm i'm
excited what here's the thing i love
dustin's story i love destiny's lore
but destiny's campaigns are never like
you know god of war last of this level
and
i don't expect them to be that right
like that's not that's not what i want
them to be
um so i always kind of temper my
expectations because
they're usually good like they're not
bad um
that being said though like there
i i feel like so we know that destiny's
development especially early on destiny
once it's
almost very turbulent and i think
they're
finally kind of getting to a point where
their original
vision is starting to like come into
play
i feel like everything we've done up
until this point
with the exception of maybe taking king
because we know that taking king was
actually part of the base game but then
cut a lot of stuff and changed a lot of
stuff i feel like that this has all been
kind of like one big side quest
essentially up until now and now we're
finally getting answers like shadow keep
was like the tip of the iceberg sort of
like all right now we're you know we're
finally getting to that point where
this is what the original edition i have
nothing to back that up i think that's
just that's just my theory
but i'm excited you know i like going
through the story once i'm obviously
gonna
have to play through it like super fast
but uh usually with destiny stories like
when i replay it the second and third
time uh my alternate characters
uh that's kind of when i let everything
sink in so right
uh i love varricks d bradley baker yeah
new friend is here yeah if he doesn't
say dismantle mines
at least once i'm gonna have to
uh the the stranger finally is back even
though they told us whatever
two years ago luke smith had that
interview oh yeah
or he's like that's always concluded
their story is done
so you know i'm excited now here's a
question for all of you that's it
do you think either we will fight
the new enemy race the darkness
presumably or see them
at the very least at some point i'll
yeah i'm going straight to you and this
we never had this talk
i don't think we will get
just that i mean that's an off-the-cuff
guess and this
expansion specifically seems built
around
hydras with legs and aramis
you have what looks to be very much a
darkness ship it is the pyramid we still
don't know who's flying these things who
parked them here
why like how they got there in the first
place it wasn't the vex it wasn't the
fallen
something else seems to be the veiled
hooded figures
there seems to be vex walking around on
these things so
i don't think they are either still here
they parked it and left as like a
you know a i can't even think the right
word but
i think they may have just parked and
left it i don't think we're gonna be
facing them yet
because in my mind it goes
uh beyond light our first like piece of
darkness powers because we could see
that aramis is able to wield stasis and
this is our first chance to do the same
thing we're actually embracing the
darkness for the first time
i think it would be a quick transition
to go hey we still think the traveler's
pretty good
sup darkness that i don't i think it's
going to have to be a little more
gradual than that
and then you go witch queen which is
this weird
kind of the only major as you said
proto-hive god that's left
probably wrong terminology but you guys
know what i mean savithoon
is the ultra hive that remains
and if we actually get to face her even
listening to bife i think he was talking
to
uh unknown player on their like crater
talk i listen to them for a little bit
i love those the fact that we see
sabathune is going to be a main enemy
even he was surprised because we had him
on before a while back and i was like
hey do you think we'll get to fight
sabathuni he's like no i don't expect to
see
i don't expect to see savithoon because
she's going to find some way
to be a proxy use anything else to
basically try and have us fight it
not directly her so the fact that if
she's like a direct enemy that's a
surprise
and then my progression then would be
light falls somehow is when we finally
actually face the ultimate
if we do the darkness or it's a decision
between them
that's where i think it would be so i
think us facing the darkness personally
is a long ways away
and that's a very long answer to get
there so who's next
i'll jump in um yo first off yeah story
trailer definitely excited to see
um liked you know i was i would i would
uh scream in that
aramis is definitely one of those
precursor kind of enemies you know
saying that
you know i i know it's not just aramis
and stuff but this is what they're
building us up for right now
to get us all geared up um i i like the
little rally call get the troops
together falling a bit broken y'all like
falling have really been
down in the dumps we've kind of
decimated them so to see her talk her
talk get the base riled up
you know and then you know say look it
makes sense the reason why i like this
story so much because it makes sense
with the fallen's history as far as
the traveler kind of rejecting them
right so to me this is the perfect thing
to embrace like yo
we're gonna take this darkness we you
know we're gonna show that damn sphere
you know you was wrong and i i love that
whole build up there so that that part's
excited me
the thing that actually threw me for a
loop though was the homie barracks i
thought
i don't know why i thought like he might
betray us but when i
actually saw it you know it was like no
he's calling out for help like this is a
distress call like he's not in
all the way on board with things and
then call me if i'm wrong did he get
like frozen by aramis or something like
that
his feet got frozen and then i went
i did this in the trailer because of
course i don't think my friend no you
did
and i'm like when it cuts back because
you see
aramis freezing like his feet he's
frozen in place holding his hands up
and then when it cuts like kind of a
dramatic swipe or whatever you wonder
like is she killing him but as soon as
it switches to her
sorry i snapped in the mic uh as soon as
it switches to her
the background changes it is not the
same place where she's standing
so i don't know if it's just like a very
good dramatic cut but i don't think
they would build up varrics and then
kill him true oh yeah
he's definitely he's playing double and
triple agent and somebody's
gonna bite him in the butt it seems it's
like yeah she found out something and
she's like no
you know you're not probably with the
cause and she's taking action so
we got to see that and then to me even
though obviously we haven't talked
they didn't talk about it then to me the
build-up for me the reason why i'm
personally excited that's about the
attic and he was just like ah that's
probably the first one i'm not too
excited but for me
the europa thing we already know was
always on the cut room floor for a long
time right
so so this is something i really want to
embrace but the thing for me
is deep stone crypt i cannot wait like i
the exos are such a unique entity
in destiny and i've always wanted to
know more and
obviously we know the history when we
did cage will and and you know he talked
about his
end to latest whatever it was the deep
stone crypt has been mentioned for so
long so i'm
curious to see if it's just going it's
going to be a whole area
is it going to be just the raid that
specifically but
that's the part i'm actually more
excited for i i would scream this is the
fake out
like we know arabis we're beating aramis
we taking your darkness
okay what's after that is it gonna be a
dreaming city situation where they open
up this whole
kind of thing like that's the part that
excite and i know bunji i feel they
holding on to that
they do they're doing this little
diversion this misdirection to act like
this is the only threat
and that's the part that excites me i
was like for me
my only thing is the best expansions
that we've had
have had good villains per se
you had oryx built up as the dad of
crota
who we fought and registered and he was
the main raid boss and there was this
awesome through line
taking kings one of the best expansions
forsaken
also up there you have aldrin who ends
up killing k and spoiler alert if you
aren't paying attention sorry
uh sorry to delight but like you know he
kills cade then we get the dreaming city
and then it's riven who's the wish thing
and then that's behind the thing
there's a big through line my only worry
is that they're giving us a trailer to a
villain
in aramis and they do they're going to
do exactly what you said they're going
to do
they're not going to i'm that's my i
mean i expect it because that's what
they do
because they've killed hive god like
worm gods in
the future
like yeah and you kill them over and
over in a strike but on the other side
it's also
they're building up a villain they're
giving her a backstory she's getting
these stasis powers
all i want is her to have a little bit
more than just like five story missions
to be killer if that's all it is
i know that's what they typically do and
i i that's where my expectations are
but i would like to see them do
something different to give this villain
a bit more life
because when we have a good vil any
movie that typically has a very good
villain typically is usually a better
movie because if you have a crappy
villain
the protagonist isn't chasing too much
and doesn't have it like you know a big
struggle
joker's like the dark knight is one of
my favorite movies because the joker's
so well done
and that's the thing is like we're
actually getting to see a little behind
the scenes of aramis and the struggle
of what she's going through and what
she's trying to put back together and
put the fallen houses together
if we go through all this and be like
all right i finally got the houses we've
got stasis
we have a chance to show the traveler
who's boss oh we killed you in four
story missions that doesn't
feel like it's justice for our first
tease of stasis and darkness powers and
that's what like
i will be disappointed but sadly hit
expectations if that's all it is so
in the back of my mind i'm hoping it's
more but again i've also played bungie
destiny campaigns so it's hard to expect
a lot more than that because even
panoptis who's really cool
we didn't know who it was i wish we got
to see more but most of those we don't
get to see
right so i'm just hoping for more that's
all i can say i'm hoping for more
but not expecting as much what i call
dominance goal syndrome like this cool
introduction great motivation great
storyline but then like we got him out
of there so quick i know what you mean i
know to me i did
callus just came on the seated don't get
me wrong no disrespect to callous but
which is cool
but it was a shame that the ark was so
quickly cut down
and i figured i i loved the ball
character i i really did so it's the
same thing i am missing
you know hopefully they they buck the
trend man hopefully you know maybe
stick around or something so i have a
i have a i have a theory go for it go
for it
let's get it um i don't think i don't
think she's actually a villain
and i think that's the spicy that's the
switch
i don't think i think we might fight
aramis but i think in the end
beyond light or at least this first part
of
the next expansions is a redemption
story i think it's all a redemption arc
at least if you want to go from a good
if you if you're looking at it from a
purely narrative structure
meaning like if you want to and i don't
know if bungie necessarily does this
but i feel like they're getting i was
like
you know like going to film school so
it's like i know that sort of that three
arc
bit and in my opinion what you see
at the end of this is you see a
character who
has been betrayed the fallen were
betrayed they were essentially
us before we were us
they're they're you know they're they're
scarred from that whole experience they
they're trying to gain back some you
know
semblance of their worth they're broken
so they turn
to this new thing i don't think it's
quite what they you know hope it will be
or maybe maybe it is and maybe they just
figure out a way that
that they can you know sort of have
their cake and eat it too they can have
this new power but they don't
necessarily need to make new enemies
because they have that new power
especially if we control it as well
and we just it just becomes a you know a
stalemate
right and then i think alderan reappears
at the end of this and i because he's
got to he's got to come
back in here somewhere and i think that
ascendant lens thing that we actually
got
from the um haunted forest
from opening the site i think that
actually is sort of the key
it might sound weird i know that they've
given out items like that and they've
never done anything before
but i think in this case that one little
item
is going to be majorly important i think
it's a clue
that we are where we're heading and
where we're heading is
we're heading back to the sort of
dreaming city marasav
alderan story arc not now but at the end
of this okay so i think that's where it
culminates it's like we get
a new ally we get a new ability and then
we get
um an uh well a return of a character an
older one and then we
push that it's like we're getting off
you know we're getting the band back
together but then we're
you know we're kind of rallying
all allies that we can i actually think
you might out even see
like the cabal somewhere join up with us
in this
somewhere along the lines because i
don't think they're inherently our
enemies
i think they're just uh pursuant
of what they find to be a mutual enemy
okay i don't know well it's
we got there he's got the the caps out
man it has been documented court
reporter you can close your book
but the website has a couple little
pieces i'll just read them off uh it
says the coming storm
a growing divide echoes in our
collective unconsciousness
precious gifts bestowed by the traveler
unspeakable evil brought forth by the
pyramids
a division spreads and distrust grows
between alliances long thought
unbreakable
the truths we hold dear will be
questioned
guardian is there more to the darkness
than we thought
so there's a little bit about if you go
to the bungee website i won't read all
these i just always that's kind of a
cool little thing just to put in the
back of your mind because as you're
saying who's good who's bad we still
have the wonder of like
when we saw the darkness at the end of
the story trailer and shadow keep and
they spoke to us in
in our forms we still haven't seen them
we will be your salvation
sabbath has been trying to block us from
actually communicating with the darkness
with the tree and eris and all those
pieces
so there's this weird they're not what
they seem but again it's like two sides
of the same coin is the traveler as good
as they say
is and it's always like i always like
the idea of perspective like
you know it's like the jedi and the sith
and i know it's like all the movies like
they have their ups and downs in star
wars and stuff but it's like
you know from my perspective you're evil
and then from your perspective my i'm
evil and it's like that piece is like
which side of the coin are we going to
end up on and it's just the fact that
they're even throwing that question out
there
is that is there more to the darkness
than we thought and it seems that way
uh go ahead you have anything no i was
just looking at that story page actually
embarrassed that i missed that but uh
yeah it's it's interesting man i'm
thinking about what what scream was
saying and um
i was actually going to ask teddy like
you know about the band being together
you know i'm saying in reference
more so to you know because we kind of
got a taste of
the the whole band being together as far
as eris you know the drifter the
stranger
i wanted to focus on on that little
group and i was just want to get your
thought process on that meeting in
reference to the
story trailer and how much of an impact
do you think they have with this um with
this expansion
i think they well
in one of the trailers not the most
recent one the stranger
looks like she's the vendor uh like the
way the camera
cuts to her it looks like she's just
standing there and you can go talk to
her
um so i'm assuming we're going to
interact with her
enough and obviously clothes brave is a
big part of this whole thing so
and that's why they brought anna back
because anna's a big part of that
um i'm sure the deep stone cryptizes and
all that so
that'll be cool as far as heiress goes
she's definitely doing something with
the darkness but i'm not i don't
claim to be a lore expert so i don't you
know i don't know exactly what's going
on there
um i've always liked the drifter but i
really don't understand like what his
motive or his
like is he just trying to survive or is
he trying to help us at the same time
like
so i i'm kind of torn on that but uh i'm
gonna be honest i don't really think
about this stuff too often
you kind of got me on the spot no that's
all i've always wanted to ask you this
you know
that's like your lord stuff yeah i just
i like the lore and destiny but i like
everyone else or most people i watch the
bike videos so
she's the man shout out shout out to the
biff man actually doing godfall videos
as well or violence yeah shout out to my
shout out to gamma
oh man dude there aren't god we had
artists lately i'm just like he's on
fire lately too yeah
bro also i want to shout out my boy
trams man trans been killing it with the
lord
yes too man shout out to trey he
actually got one of the biggest kudos
for his one of his videos
um morela saluted him so
we've been we've been supporting trans
trans we got to get you in on the
campfire as well brother
love what you're doing keep up the good
work man definitely but yeah i mean
is it this is there's a lot of threads
going on you know see a lot of threads a
lot of stuff
it's an exciting time i always you know
it e you know how we get like
we get we we have our expectation what
we hope it could be
you know saying there's few times no
disrespect that they really
go that far you're like oh my god they
hit it with that
and there's most of the time it's like
okay it's what we expected
you know boom boom beeline to aramis and
then
you know whatever what happened have any
of you watched lost
yep yes yeah okay oh yeah oh yeah so
somehow lost had all these threads that
seemingly a lot of them never got
answered a lot of them didn't matter i
kind of feel like destiny's like that in
a way
that's a good one except except it's a
longer
uh experience because 10 years instead
of uh i think six years was for lost
yeah
um and there's just all these things
where i'm like you got to start giving
me answers now we're
we're approaching your what we're
approaching
so like i need answers to things that
you've introduced in year one
like we gotta we gotta you know i need
to know what the smoke monster is
that's it that's five yeah
that's the darkness in this in this
thing but it's been
it's going to be ten years or nine years
till we might know what the smoke
monster is and you're like are you
like really come on like yeah and shout
out to apex we we even forget
the nine like yeah the island is just
this arbitrary thing we could go on with
that too right it's just
it's so many threads it's like you said
that's a perfect analogy
there's just yeah and i and i don't know
if you guys have this like i did but i
watched lost as it aired
like oh every week i definitely caught
it later
yeah and i waited uh yeah i watched the
uh
i watched the first season of loss and
then i watched the last episode of loss
and i was like okay
that's that's fair like makes sense
because everything in between
three was probably better than the rest
but yeah yeah yeah it's
the first three of the best but yeah
that's that's kind of i feel like we're
at that point where
like i just just tell me just tell me
what things are like yeah
i i don't i don't need this like tease
anymore there's a grand reveal at the
end but that just makes more questions
come up
and as a side note because we're talking
about this earlier i forgot to mention
this
how do you guys feel about fighting the
fallen in their fourth
form oh yeah that is the fourth form
isn't it
because we've had siva and
taken and now ice
sorry cosmic ice stasis stasis yeah yeah
and scorn but yeah
that's right dead fallen live following
zombie fallen
look man you're desperate man resources
done everything they can
exactly
they hold the foot down i can't get mad
at that one look i get it i get it we
got
expansions we got a seasonal format to
adhere to
we got to stretch this thing out man
ain't that much in the comfort so we got
a remix
remix
[Laughter]
at least for me for fallen or something
like
they feel this one seems cool because
they are almost on
as you said they did like the traveler
was with them
like basically bailed on them and helped
us out and we're kind of see
what that's like and we do get to see
something
humanoid-ish and i'm giving that very
very loosely
but you have like we've seen varrix a
little bit we've seen skull loss and
we've
never really like and it's been a while
kind of since we've kind
kind of come back to varrix and just to
see somebody like him come full circle
that's actually fairly cool to see that
come i mean they're they're bringing
stuff as you guys have said we've been
like
they're they're taking like year one of
destiny 2 and just
kind of throwing it away because they're
putting it in the vault and then you
have like year one with the stranger and
year two with uh
oryx and that connection kinda doesn't
seem to have gone through because that's
gonna connect to sabathun later on
and then we have the prison of elders
now coming back in year
seven like they've they're pulling some
of that old stuff out and there's this
weird like stuff in the middle
but we're not gonna use it but at least
as like long time destiny players i'm
actually excited
to see varrix and the stranger and then
eris and all this stuff come together
because these are stuff we've seen for a
while we talked about this i think last
time though
if you take uh a new person who buys
beyond light
they don't they haven't played destiny 1
they haven't
seen anything that came before forsaken
and you have anything and if especially
if they go buy the forsaken campaign
who's this exo who gets shot why do i
care
and then it comes into some of this
stuff and it's like for us this is
actually a really good campaign
to continue very old things but new
players to the game are
gonna be a little thrown off i wonder
how that's actually gonna be for a new
player experience
i'm excited about like where this stuff
can go and as you said scream like some
crazy theories of where it can actually
get to but as like a new player i wonder
how they're going to be able to explain
where the hell any of this stuff comes
from like they're they don't do like
storyboard backstory like we talked
about like ghost of sushi
really cool like storyboards for like
legends and a quick like here's a little
history real fast
yeah if they don't do anything like that
for some of these characters there's
going to be some very
lost people i think i i agree or it's
going to say
click here and go to biff's video but i
mean
shout out to the hobie but yeah yeah
they definitely got to do something with
it with the onboarding just to get
people
caught up because they can't assume that
everyone's been there from day one like
us
they just can't you know i'm saying
there's people that not gonna have any
you know they're not gonna understand
the significance of the actual stranger
being here
right they just they not it's gonna have
no context it's just some random exo
check like again so it's on bungie you
know right
like you said a perfect example
storyboard or even when destiny 2
first launched and well they kind of did
it for the people that were returning
players like you know okay we defeated
the great rx we did this then we did
like they need that
to get if they want to take their
narrative seriously right
if they don't if they don't want to do
patchwork and putting it together you
need to do that kind of stuff because
you
do have a great foundation you do have a
great story here it's just a matter of
telling it correctly so
we'll see hoping hoping that yeah i was
like there's a little character tidbits
on those pages that mentions like
varric's
after helping aldrin escape the prison
of elders of eric's has only recently
emerged from hiding an uneasy ally in
the fight against aramis
he is a shrewd opportunist who wants to
do good even if his choices are always
suspect and that kind of nails it pretty
well
we don't trust him he's not completely
bad apparently he helped aldrin escape
so he's like he just does stuff for his
own self but he doesn't have a
completely crappy heart
yeah so it's like sometimes it's in the
right place but like if his motivations
win that's what's gonna happen he's
he's an odd duck and then you've got the
stranger and mysterious exo has not been
seen
since the fla the fall of the black
garden
that is the only mention as to why
everybody on this podcast and probably
hardcore people know
but a new person maybe beyond like what
the hell's black garden wit where
like what is that is that ever going to
be and will they actually is that
something they're going to talk about in
the story like
from the black garden what were you
doing we saw you back then is it now
where have you been for six years all
that type of stuff um
and then hers is like with her
experience her experience will guide
guardian's understanding of the power of
stasis so she's actually going to be the
one probably guiding us through
understanding stasis powers so the
vendor part seems fitting yep
aris when you see the story trailer
first for her the cinematic trailer that
was like
quote e3 or whatever you see her like
holding her like basically the stasis on
the ground around her when she's
standing on the ice sheet
she's got a couple crystals around her
so she's doing something with the
darkness
and the drifter as you said smooth
talker good or bad
we would never know so i mean we've got
like we have some cool characters i keep
calling them the anti-vanguard because
it's three people
all related to the darkness in some way
kind of broken off from like
the ways of the light but i mean
i also didn't know it says uh a survivor
and unsupeable horrors aerys is a former
hunter i did not know she was actually a
hunter
really yeah i didn't actually catch that
at some point but yeah she is
so i believe that drifter is also
warlock
yes well then the stranger looks way too
much like a hunter so titans got screwed
in her defense she comes from a
different timeline
maybe she's not even one of the three
classes we have
maybe she's something else
so she's got that weird ghost i want a
fish ghost i don't
fish something it's not a ghost
i was like overall it's like i want to
see where the story goes i hope they
give it just a little more
it's got to be it i would love to see it
kind of in the
level of the taking kings and the
forsakens because if it's like
burst of osiris and panoptis or zal and
warmind i'm gonna be bummed
because they're actually giving a
trailer to a villain and we haven't had
that in a while
so feels like it deserves a little bit
of something
so yeah that's the first thing that
happened and then as we knew the sandbox
was coming
now this is where cognito i know
crucible man
teddy playing a little bit of everything
he's unbroken amongst everything else he
has it all
and scream of course holding his own i'm
the schlub in pvp in this group damn
we have some changes and we got some
of like specifics about weapon types and
certain things
uh before we actually dive into
specifics
do you guys feel this was like the
crucible sandbox like twab or was this
like the general sandbox swab
what you guys feeling know how i feel uh
probably this feels more like a crucible
fix but in typical destiny fashion it
negatively impacts pve unnecessarily
or it could be vice versa it usually
goes both ways but
uh yeah i mean i got a lot to say about
this but let's see
what do you think scream um
yeah short answer yeah
yeah i don't think that i mean i don't
even know
nothing about that was pve to me
whatsoever
it was all pvp to me i mean you're talk
if you're talking hand cannons
honestly you're only really talking pvp
i mean i i
there there's some cases where you might
use a hand cannon in certain pve content
if it's like the right thing
for you know they have the right burn
and it has the right kind of perks for a
specific
encounter if you're doing like a
nightfall or something like that but for
the most part
there's no reason to bring a hand cannon
into a pve
like scenario you just like you know and
the whole thing and with snipers
like you know it was just it seemed to
be catered specifically
to not just pve but to risk versus
reward kind of situations
so you know like that sniper
hand cannon combination in my opinion
always
should have been the best combinat like
the fastest killing combination
the the most risky because you have to
be the most proficient with it to make
it work properly
but if you're good with those two
weapons you should be able to
dominate in pvp because they're hard to
use
so if they're hard to use that means
they should be really good
and that's why that's kind of the
messaging i got
yeah before we dive cog thoughts uh i
just wanted to get the feel but i was
like yeah i'm kind of getting the answer
i was hoping for
so the non-spoiler feel of
yeah just like how did you feel what who
is this like sandbox like
no it's four this is this is a crucible
you know like this is this is again what
teddy said that it's gonna probably
adversely affect bbe
but yeah this is this is me this is this
was all selfishly
everything i wanted to hear for the
crucible sandbox
and a lot of archetypes that i'm very i
cannot wait to dive into this because
there's a lot of archetypes i have
very strong feelings about so yeah this
is definitely you have
feelings i know i'm so strongly feelings
i know it's rare for me to express my
mind so the first
giant one and i'm just gonna unpack all
of this and let you guys go to town
because there's a lot to unpack here
and cannons so they're making changes to
give hand cannons sub families more
diversity and more reasons to use each
aggressive now by the way if you guys
don't know aggressive
and then the number that i put next to
these they're the same thing so it could
be rpms like 110s 120s which are now the
same which is a thing
uh 150s 140s 180s or lightweight
adaptive aggressive
they have different names they all mean
the same stuff so i'll try and same
together
aggressive frames these are your 110 rpm
hand cans
are now 120 rate of fire hand cannons
they broke out aggressive hand cannons
allowing custom tuning of stats
uh for example damage fall off for a
full range bar
uh is now starting at 32 meters
that's aggressives and they have kind of
a separate stat workout as opposed to
the other hand cannons
adaptive and precision um
this is kind of everything lumped uh
range stat now has more impact on
minimum damage falloff for both
archetypes
damage falloff for 100 range and what
they mean by that is if you have your
range bar
fully maxed out if you're able ever able
to do that to your gun this is what it
means
damage falloff for 100 range now starts
at 25 meters
instead of 20. so the damage fall-off
starts farther out for all of these hand
cannons
precision hand cannons your 180 rate of
fires have a magazine scaled up by 37
these are your fastest firing hand
cannons 37 more ammo
that one i'm probably okay with but i'll
still let you guys decide this also
affects exotics with that rate of fire
is malfeasance like a 180 i think if i
remember right yeah so that's the thing
shout out to the mouth easy lightweight
folded into adaptive this is probably
one of the bigger ones
moved all lightweight hand cannons
that's 150 rate of fire
into the 140 rate of fire family this
also means
the intrinsic properties of lightweights
faster movement faster handling
that is now gone 150s are 140s
and act like 140s to every aspect that
they can
this includes luna's hal not forgotten
and then they say one exotic hand cannon
will retain the 150
uh rate of fire it's sunshot i had a
couple other nice teases but it's
sunshine
but at this time they said the
lightweight 150 rate of fire hand
cannons represent the majority of hand
cannon usage in the crucible
most of you guys probably know why
they're the best bang for buck
yeah time to go while we experiment with
many different while we experimented
with many different ways to even out
light weights and adaptives lightweight
hand cannons consistently
retained a faster time to kill as such
we optimize opted to equalize the rate
of fire
we selected 140 rate of fire as it fair
that is fairly balanced in the crucible
sandbox it gives other weapon types more
time to breathe between shots
avoids an over abundance of hand cannons
with faster ttk than other weapons
and it pairs lies nicely with the
upcoming changes of 600 uh auto rifles
we'll get to that a bit later
so that's everything happening to hand
cannons we got more range
150s are now 140s 180s get more ammo
range is kind of all over what do you
guys think this is whoever wants to dive
in
go for it i better go cause i got a lot
go go for it scream i've been i'm gonna
go first a couple times okay uh
yeah i'll just sort of i guess i kind of
said my piece a little bit already but
just to kind of
uh continue on that same theme
um risk versus reward is what
pvp in destiny needs to be
it's what it was in d1 it's what made in
my opinion crucible
awesome in d1 i loved the crucible in d1
it's what's made it kind of boring in d2
is that there's just no reason to use
some of these weapons
like why isn't why wasn't a 110 like a
110
right in the right hands should be
unbeatable
it should just be it should be not easy
to use but
the person who can use it it should have
the fastest time to kill
it should be like if you hit a body shot
with a sniper and you switch over to a
hand cannon
it's boom boom two shots done that's it
at a long range they should definitely
in my opinion they should have the
longest range
of any weapon just
i mean it's just that's what it should
be if it's the hardest hitting weapon
then it's got to have the longest range
um
we'll get to a counter point to that
later continue
[Music]
but okay don't get spicy in a minute i
do i do think they've
done good service in sort of
lumping some of these things together uh
i think that sun sunshot will be because
that's the only one that's staying 150
they said
that will be sort of a secret meta oh
yeah shout out to sunshine
you know i don't know what um i don't
think that will be the one that
necessarily is best paired with like
something like a sniper rifle i think
the
the 120s now will be like you're going
to see a lot of
120 hand cannons and a lot of sniper
rifles uh
i think that's just going to be the new
meta i mean it's sort of the new old
meta because if you go back to like
i don't know year one d1 that was really
what everybody
i mean the the top tier players that's
what they use
let me back you up a second um what i
have to ask you this question
what about 150s you know 140s kind of
rolling in at 150s rolling in to get
that specific i want your feedback where
are you at because you play crucible a
lot
like where you're at with one for
everything being 140.
i think there might be a um
i think 140s are going to be the role
weapons meaning
you got to find the rights you got to
find the right stats for them they're
not going to be
they're not going to be like out of the
box
good all the time i think there's going
to be a certain level of like 120s
if you can like any 120
will be fairly good um better with
obviously the right perks on it to add
to
aim assist and things like that but in
general
i don't think 140s are really going to
be the ones to use
um actually 150 or 140s
might be like the pve hand cannon
okay i think that i think that the
uh one the 120s are going to be
the top tier and i think that the 180s
will sort of be that like the weapon the
people who don't use hand cannons but
need to complete a bounty for hand
cannons
that's what they use shout out to those
i don't
shout out to those dudes and then yeah
and then i think the one
though i think well i mean the fact that
that's easy
he was like all excited should just be
referred to as
the hand cannons that you grinded
forever to get and nobody uses anymore
[Music]
some people like them i am awful with
them i can't use them
i always i always loved them like i the
loon is held and not forgotten
they had a good run what did he had a
little good run for a minute it was it
was hot
as hell and a 150 they are now i guess
they were 180s they were they weren't
they were native okay yeah now they're
watching these but
um yeah i always i mean i did i did sort
of like them
uh i liked the idea of them i wish that
they had kind of
um you know i always thought hand
cannons were sort of that weapon that
like
the way you fire it is as much a part of
it being effective as
regardless of of the rounds per minute
and i always thought like the 180s were
were really good
but you didn't feel like you were
shooting a hand cannon you just kind of
felt like you were shooting
like sort of like a pulse rifle almost
to a certain extent with that kind of
ain't you'd always be ads'ing
yeah um you know they you'd hit fire if
they got close
but if you wanted to get any range
you're more often adsing
and like i always was kind of a fan of
that sort of like
snapshot sort of shooting in d1 where
you would use
it was sort of a trick on like the heavy
hand cannons where you would like
aim down sight but then as soon as you
pulled the trigger
you'd let off and you would get that
like added bit of auto
auto aim from like the hip fire and and
the
ads and i and like that's i don't know
that's like
you need that kind of stuff because
that's skill gap right there like the
ability to use a weapon
in that's you know not blatantly right
in front of you
and to kind of get around certain angles
of it to make it more effective
that is where skill gap is really that's
where you find it in fps's
and i don't feel like that was ever
really a thing in d2 like i didn't
i you know i never really understood
what the where the skill gap laid as far
as the meta
so much as just whether or not you were
you know you you had the the best weapon
at that time
or you know you were just a real sweaty
on the mouse and keyboard and you could
slide and
like hit fire shot like with without you
know
any thought behind it so
you know that's kind of i i don't know
if i answered your question with that
but i do think that like
yeah i'm sure you covered it somewhere
in there you got it i think yeah 140s
might be the the pve
pancake okay if there is one teddy ted
can you repeat the question well what
just
it's like i mean the 180s the 140s the
120s is what we have
what do you think about where everything
looks like it's gonna settle for beyond
light in the world of hand cannons do
you like it
hate it cool with it want to see how it
falls so
i pretty much for most of justine's life
have not used hand cannons wow like i'll
use like kind of what scream said like
i'll use them if the situation
calls for that if that is required thing
yeah whatever right
but like or trying yeah yeah right
but like i don't i've never had this
like fascination with them
um unlike yeah i understand why people
like them
i think what's really interesting uh
about
anytime they adjust hand cans or talk
about hand cannons is that initially in
their like very early stages of destiny
one you can actually see this in one of
the vidocs i think it was the first one
hand cannons were a special weapon yes
uh and so
every time they do stuff like this i i
kind of think about that and like
this this long train of decisions that
have or these
design choices that have come because
they chose not to make it a special
weapon
um now you know let's move forward to d2
and like catch up a little bit so
d2 kind of scream was saying they sort
of eliminated the skill gap
and they slowly introduced it back into
the game every now and again
and then people get all in a tizzy about
it because they're like i can't
you know this guy on the mouse and
keyboard doing whatever right and like
and then they dial everything back again
and i feel like this is definitely the
their answer to let's dial it back a
little bit and let's um
let's kind of condense everything
because essentially now there's what
uh three you know four or four arc types
of hand cannons right now
one twenty one eighty and one the other
three without saying well fifty still
exists technically
yeah so they're definitely you know
they're condensing it down it's probably
you know these are
easier balancing now i think what i
don't like on paper reading this is that
this essentially just neuters hand
cannons again
mostly for the most part um people are
obviously still going to use them people
are still you know like scream was
saying they're gonna there's gonna be a
new
it could be the 120 could be the one for
whatever right what happened
um it it just
to me this just seems like there's
there's too much data that's like
overwhelming of you hand cannon usage
and they're like we gotta we gotta tone
this down
this is a very we gotta adjust this and
now to their credit they said they
experimented a lot with different
solutions and this was the one that made
the most sense to them
right um so yeah we'll see
i'm mostly different about this specific
question yeah
the rest of it i got a lot to say but
this
this this is what it is for me this hair
hey let me jump in oh so go ahead yeah
go ahead
i'm sorry because i'm very passionate
about this one um
you know look hand cannons is definitely
a thing for me you know i'm saying i've
always that's kind of the first weapon i
gravitated towards last where it was
probably one of the worst exotics i
grabbed
towards um this i'm
i'm torn i understand the logic behind
the decisions
i still need to see it play out the
thing that was surprising all right
first of all
overall there were too many archetypes
that let's just get that out so the rpms
it was it was way too very i agree with
the consolidation
i'm with screen one well now 120s which
were formerly 110s
needed love that like i whip
scream with your whole conceptual vision
it's a skill weapon if it hits that hard
you know you should be rewarded right
and i never felt one tens
got to deserve like i had a god roll
duke mk whatever and
i felt that should have been something
you shout out to the duke you already
know rapid hit
kill club whatever you had what you do
like
you're gonna still the same
right you know head at the time same
time to kill so you're like why are you
there
right now it's a destiny one
cut gun it's in the first fight oh wow
yeah it's also the only gun in destiny 2
that has the same
like perk tree as a destiny one gun well
yes
yeah it is unique yep it is that way
yeah man so
dude like i always felt like yeah the
rate of fire i might get out shot but if
i pace my shots with
how accurate like i feel i should win
the gunfight if you know i use skill
so i'm cool i'm excited for 120s i am
excited
i like that part the the questionable
part where everyone's going crazy on
twitter and i get it
is the 150 as of right now in the
sandbox 150
is the hand cannon if you're not using
150
you ain't doing hand cannon right so to
lump i thought it was going to go the
opposite i thought well 40s were going
to go into 150
but then they said no 150 in i mean what
the opposite so now
we have to see the new meta because
prior
600 rpms is out here we're going to get
to autos right
the thing that may save this matter will
i overreact
is call me if i'm wrong teddy didn't
a couple of twabs ago like hand cannon
range
almost the stat didn't matter anymore
like whatever you visually saw like they
like reigned it back in
e right where the the like it really
didn't even matter if you had like this
super high range
hand cannon because it was like neutered
and the most you would get is a certain
set figure
there's a cool guy video i'm sure about
that too shout out to cool guy we've had
a ball before so the vibe i got now is
hand cannons are going to get their
range back
they may not have the efficiency of the
150
but we got to see it and with with um
screams what point
it's going to come down to the perk
combinations i want to see how that
rolls you know saying
as far as efficiency but um yeah and
then the only last point i'll say is
that
i don't know where 180s is going to be
i i don't know what i i i wish
yeah good yeah just bounty weapons
yeah like i don't know about it 185 i
could
see again we don't have i don't have it
in front of me we don't have the met
we're just guessing
based on all the data they're giving or
they're actually giving us
but um the way it sits for me like 120
should be okay
one um 40s we gotta see but one eighties
i don't know but
i'm gonna give it to you man like i it
was an interesting choice it was very
very interesting this one with her
with hair cannon uh i was like i will
say
hand cans i have mixed use as i said i
am trash with 180 some people enjoy them
like some people enjoy their malfeasance
some people have enjoyed what was the
seventh serif weapon some people were
like hey this one actually
i pick a 180 up and i'm like what am i
doing with it doesn't even feel
right like but she does have a very
specific thing about fields of weapons
and
certain people are like hey this weapon
feels good to me those feel like a
dumpster fire in my hands and i cannot
explain why
they feel awful to me and and trust me
there's people better that's totally
fine but
140s 150s have been decent but i'm with
you also as well
the duke was always in a weird spot
because if they made that a two shot
it would have to almost be like a 90 to
not
be overpowered for time to kill because
if it was like a 0.6
time to kill with two headshots i'll
forget it then you're like okay
uh that's a problem so then it's like
so they made it a 120. so now basically
what they're saying is
you the 120s and 140s are probably going
to have the same time to kill if you're
standing right next to each other
the 120s you're gonna have to play
farther at range
that's basically what they're kind of
making this to because they didn't
change
time to kill damaged numbers none of
that it's all about the range stat and
how those two play
and then unfortunately as you said like
the 180s now they have more in the
magazine so yeah i can pull the trigger
faster
but the skill on either of those two
other ones even
like a 120 is still pr i can't i'm with
you it's like i honestly as you say that
i don't know where
180s go especially in a crucible setting
in a pve setting
maybe something where it's like you've
got more bullets in the magazine hand
cannon still hits kind of hard enough to
where you can like
single shot thralls or something and
you're going around mowing down enemies
maybe it has a pve place
yeah and that might be why the magazine
piece is in there but overall
like that that could be my only guess
if you pick up a 180 you may as well tie
your hands behind your back together
because
it doesn't feel like there's a lot of
benefit there because the range seems to
match the 140s
and you're not going to kill them any
quicker i don't think so in my mind
yeah i was like 180s might be a pve
thing like if
you know maybe it's efficient and you
have like maybe i don't know what 37
of the magazine is but if say you have
18 bullets in a hand can and you're able
to one tap
like red bars once you're high enough or
something like that for single enemies
that might be efficient
in there they they may be alluding to
that
again because again magazine's scaling
up 37 in pvp
doesn't you know doesn't really do
anything so unless they introduce
obviously sun setting we're going to
introduce a whole new line of 180s right
and maybe they should hopefully
introduce some exciting new perk
combinations
that make it a good pve
i know i know i'm asking i know i'm like
a new combination i'm like man you have
higher expectations than i do no
i don't know i'm shooting for the stars
again i know
perkin kill damage perk oh
reloading damage period dance hey outlaw
got buffed recently we'll get into that
you never know i can shoot for the stars
sometimes man i mean
but i'm with you it's just a curious
why the magazine up like you know say so
to me that alludes to
you're doing something with that
archetype and i'm just going to try to
be hopeful
in the people so i mean overall hand
cannons it feels like
we'll have to see um they were a little
bit
of a mess and they had to find some they
they did say they tried the testing they
gave it an effort the 140s
you're sitting right next to each other
anyway so yeah at some point one of them
had to go one way
if the if everybody if everybody's heads
are exploding in solar fire and crucible
we all know sunshine won the meta
outside of that get ready for the emblem
get ready for that you survived this
sunshine man
get ready for the emblem it's not going
to be probably that bad but there might
be a lot of heads
blowing off the pancakes melting yeah
now if i have ever read a piece of a
twab that is designed for crucible more
than this i don't know
diaper rifles we want sniper rifles to
feel powerful without being too easy to
use so they dominate
i'm like when i read that sentence
before i got to any other line i was
like
huh i wonder what they're going to do
adjust how aim assist is
affected by sniper rifle zoom level low
zoom scopes have a
less aim assist higher zoom scopes have
more aim assist
scopes with around 50 zoom or unchanged
basically all they're doing to sniper
rifles now some of you guys may have
been newer to the game
sniper rifles got a buff then they chop
the legs off of that buff
and we're at a point where sniper rifles
not are not an amazing place in pve
and the only thing they are changing is
the aim assist that is related to the
scope
zoom period if you're picking up what i
was putting down
you don't sound thrilled i'm going to
take this one because oh my word
so sniper rifles got a 20 buff oh they
were actually in the meta
the big giant issue this is always like
what is what's the problem
or what's the source of the problem
what's the source of the problem you
make encounters that are far away you
can't get close to things so you force
us into using sniper rifles we're gonna
make them powerful
everybody uses sniper rifles let's knock
those down
okay now we have to go use something
else but the encounters are still the
same
that's the like that's the overall
arcing issue they even like at one point
when they took the reflection damage out
of sleeper we're like
are we gonna get a weird crazy encounter
no it's a boss floating in the sky
of course you're gonna snipe that thing
like or a boss that runs away and you
have to sit there and shoot it and do
damage and chase it down a hallway but
it's faster than you are like
they are designed for long range damage
and yet
they don't want us to use sniper rifles
so sniper rifles are no stronger and
this is
all now somebody like merculy's fallout
cool guy
kami the whole uh what is their podcast
oh you know what i'm talking about i'm
trying to uh fire
range firing range yeah like the five
range guys they will like go full ham on
what this means for like every sniper
like is beloved good does this one suck
like what does it mean for everything
that's them but for me i read this and
i'm like all right
yeah what about you guys
even teddy where y'all at man snipers
let's uh let's take a trip down memory
lane for a second
so so if we go back to season of
opulence what was the pve meta
it was mountaintop recluse energy that's
what you put on
and that was pretty bust that was
recluse at its peak mountaintop at its
peak anarchy hasn't been changed
actually um then for shadow keep they
were like we're going to buff snipers
izanagi's skyrocketed up to usage
and i could kind of fell out of out of
the meta and
lo and behold they gave us a boss
encounter in the raid
where you have to stand very far away
from the boss
and shoot it with a sniper it's almost
like they planned this buff
right and then six months later
they literally control z'd the buff
and just undid the whole thing and they
were like we're just putting it back to
the thing but then
what came out of this was the changes
they did to crucible
in shadow keep to snipers which i'm
reading this
and aim assist is definitely part of the
issue
yeah zooms once again like when they
announced this like a month and a half
ago
is not the problem bunji your maps are
too small for me to justify
a large zoom your problem is flinch
if i shoot someone with a high caliber
pulse
rifle four four round bursts and i hit
all four shots
and then this has been proven like a
thousand videos they're aiming at my
body and then my shot
auto lines them up to my head that
should not
happen amount of times that that happens
is so frustrating so me reading this
going half of this is scope changes
right and the other half is the aim
assist
in tandem with the scopes that's not the
problem like
that isn't the issue people
people play snipers because there's a
low risk high reward
i can stand far away snipe a lane or
whatever and granted there's a few
exceptions to this rule where like
people do the crazy stuff with the
warlock and get off the map and i think
that's
that's fine because you you've already
outskilled you were going to beat me
regardless of whether you
you did that or not right so
this is this is probably the one that
bothers me the most on this list uh
because it's something that frustrates
the most in pvp besides uh cheaters but
i can't control that right so um so just
for the record
you would have also you're cool with
this
but you would have also wanted flinch
adjustment
and uh damage increase in pve
no no damage i think damage is fine okay
pretty much every sniper it's literally
just a flinch i think flinch is the
problem
uh specifically the issue of like if i
shot them first
and they were either aiming like a
little bit off for me or at my body and
then they just immediately poke me in
the head
i think that's that this needs to go
like that that doesn't fit with their
their less skill gap uh philosophy that
they have with a lot of these changes or
in general a lot of the changes they
make it's it's almost like a
you basically you lost the engagement
but we're gonna give you a freebie we're
gonna free
thank you that's essentially what it is
uh
and yeah i mean that's what i say about
it like yeah
no i'm with you bro i'm just tired of
snipers
that goes like that ties so much into
like you had the boss encounter this
thing you have to shoot far away and
it's the same thing you said with the
crucible maps like
this we're on six v6s and we haven't had
a map size that's been worthwhile of a
long range sniper in d2
period we started with fours some of
those maps are still around
and there might be like one or two lanes
maybe
like i can think of convergence i think
is the one with the three hallways like
the
one from d1 like that's one i can
picture that has long hallways but
yeah it's like okay high zoom scope have
a small increase
where and we'll get to another archetype
that still pisses me off and that's two
down but we'll get there too it's just
like
they make all these maps for and now
you're giving hand cannons longer range
so then if you are trying to snipe
you're gonna let this guy from halfway
across the map
still poke me with a hand cannon when
i'm sorry and this is where scream me
we may differ i don't care how much of a
revolver this 120 is
you're still not probably going to be
that accurate from that far away you
should not be able to even remotely be
able to like graze me with a bullet
if i'm doing a sniper scope can i ask
can i can i push back
what a hand cannon can do well i
understand your point on
on hand can and distance and and and
affecting that but
like i i'm with teddy here that if i'm
shooting a sniper
aiming down sights in the face
i should move you off your square i
totally agree i'm not angry
flinch i'm totally okay no no no no i i
thought you were
okay i don't know okay so no if i have a
yeah i might go
figure i can't tell you how many times
i'm like bam
and i'm like how do i hit you with four
shots and you're still on me you should
be like
you should be looking over at the next
wall or something like there
there's this little known game called
halo yeah
and uh when you get shot while you're
scoped into the sniper you know what
happens you get too scoped
yo isn't that revolutionary and then and
then
then the onus is on you as a player to
aim that tiny reticle on their head and
hit them while you're too scoped and
while you're being flinched too if you
don't halo one and two
then halo 1 and 2 didn't have flinch uh
on those on that gun specifically but
um why hasn't that ever been
a thing that they've tried
yeah because because because then then
putting on a sniper actually becomes
like a choice it's a skill weapon yeah
it's not it's not a default
it's it's like oh i have to think about
this more than just
go get shot aim assistance it's a play
style where you're like i'm gonna play
farther back
i'm gonna have a different play style
that's like my special weapon that's
how i'm going to play that part of like
my game not slide sniping around
i'm like i don't even under like now
there are people who are skilled and
they understand the mechanics of the way
the game was programmed
i get it drag scoping is a thing in my
head that is just broken
and that's just me that's one of those
things like there are moments i get a
shot and i'm like
that should not have happened i'm with
you and that's one of those things there
are people who
like literally i watch like countless
highlight reels
where they lit they're like aim here's
the guy they're aiming at a pillar
they drag it across and they know when
to pull the trigger and i'm like
that's a skill that somebody's like and
that's a thing and that's a skill but
for me
and i'm i'm 37 years old maybe i'm just
too old to get it but
like that's a point to where like if
like
that should be a skill like you've got
it you see them come out you move it you
click it not like
hey here they're running let me drag it
across their head and like catch it
you know like that wide scope that just
just grabbing up the averages and just
boom pinching your head off your beauty
sir you get it sir
you got it you you touched it i got so i
got so excited
yeah but i was like that's one of those
things where like the entire firing
range podcast would be like
well that's just a get good moment and
that's that's the way the game is made
i mean potentially that's you decide to
play that way or you don't
but like the whole flinch thing is like
if you do put multiple shots into people
i can't i agree like if i either move it
to where it's not even close
like i'm way over here or as you said
maybe you hit your entire clip
or a couple shots with a scout or you
know a certain number of shots like you
take them out of that that would be
i just i would love to see what that
would do like you see somebody and i've
got
and that's where like scout rifles might
actually have a function at that point
but
um that would be interesting to see just
some ways
for flinch to actually be a real thing
scream how we feeling snipers
i actually have a question to add to
everybody um yes
in at the onset of beginning of d2
um how did everybody feel about snipers
then because they've changed quite a bit
since then there was a lot of
everybody had problems with them
obviously they were heavy so
that was a problem but like there was an
issue with the flint
remember they actually they actually had
to like go in and reprogram something
with the flinch because it was
causing unnecessary kind now is that the
kind of flinch that you think
would i don't think that was the best uh
solution to a problem but
um versus now do you think that was a
sort of a better meta as far as how they
function say we had that level of flinch
but they were
um you know obviously they're not
heavies anymore would that yeah
do you think that would be sort of a
good balance or anything
if i could honestly say i remember what
that felt like i could give an honest
answer
it's been so long but it was like
i was like for them heavies it's like i
don't even remember because they were
like
they didn't matter then it was a little
too much from what i remember
uh i'd have to like watch some footage
but i i do remember like you you'd get
disco
or not disco the flinch was really bad
like you'd like someone would shoot you
super far away because
scout rifles mighta oh yeah scout rifles
with king yeah and
and you you get like one you know i
remember on midtown like spawning in at
a
and why don't some person shoot with
like one bullet and you're it would
you're all over the place so i think i
think that was a little too much
but the sweet spot somewhere in the it's
somewhere there uh whenever they did the
flinch adjustment which i think was
shadow keep
um i think that's that's when it like
turned too much uh
because you remember when when forsaken
came around and they gave us the special
weapon
slot and snipers moved to the special
weapon they were not the predominant
used uh special uh that they didn't
happen until later
um so yeah yeah it's good it's good you
just want to get thoughts real quick
so so yeah so to kind of
um comment on what you guys said i
absolutely agree with teddy
that um as someone who played a ton of
halo
and you needed to be good with a sniper
if you wanted to be competitive and i
played competitive halo
uh the way that that sniper worked not
in
uh well i think they changed it a little
bit in def
and halo 5. i can't really remember i
didn't play it that much it was sort of
the same though
yeah um but that is in my opinion
the best way to do a sniper in a game
like you you can scope
and if you get shot you're out of scope
you don't really get a kick
so much as you're just not scoped in
anymore because again
i look at it in terms of what builds
skill gap
so if you're able in halo
something that a lot of people would do
something that i would do all the time
is you would aim down sight and you
would
you would just try to you you know you
try to get
a sense of where people were going to be
so you needed to know the lanes you
needed to know the spawns that was part
of it
but then you would sometimes just try to
get close
and if you're if you were trying to
really flex on somebody you'd wait for
them to shoot you and then you'd shoot
right as they did
and you get the no-scope headshot from
like a
from a scope and you get that from the
smash exactly that was the best wasn't
it oh i love
that when the announcer would say it's
snapshot like that
so good buy it and uh
and you had to be able to know scope
with the sniper
in uh in halo now of course it doesn't
work that way and do you want in destiny
because
um you don't have a reticle when you're
not scoping right
you're not adsing um that's also
kind of i mean the reason that the slide
sniper is like slide
snapshot sniping is like so popular is
because
there is that little bit of flinch and
if you slide and you're low and somebody
shoots you
the kick is going to go right up to the
head so that's what they do that little
bit of kick goes right to the head the
auto aim picks it up
and that's it and you don't get and
because you don't get knocked out
it's like it it becomes actually really
easy at that point
you just have to kind of get the rhythm
and it's like
it's funny enough and like in d1 uh you
know occasionally
my i would put out like uh a little bit
of a montage
i was not yeah you did i didn't i didn't
really promote them too much but
occasionally i put out a montage and i
would get comments all the time
of like why are you why why so damn much
because i would just be constantly
swapping out you know like i
wouldn't ever ads i would just
constantly be swapping my sniper
back and forth just why why why why
keeping my sniper going
because in halo that was something you
always wanted
to control yeah get it right right yeah
and it will kind of bring you back up to
a level point yeah exactly why why
and and you want to always be able to
have just that one button away
right to hit that body shot and then
swap over
i have one let me see how much dust is
on there
this one this one's actually nice
you owed what let me see that i have an
xbox thingy upstairs it's just my
immediate unit dude
like you leaning into the camera you can
actually see more i love that yeah
bring it closer i gotta see i'm sorry we
gotta sign check continue
there for a second i was shocked i was
like that exists in your house continue
yeah so like i would get comments of
like why you know you don't need to do
that man like why are you doing that
and i'd be like well i'm checking my
radar or i'm trying to
keep my reticle level you know i'm
trying to keep that sort of
there wasn't a reticle when you were hip
firing but like sort of you could keep
that sort of theoretical reticle right
in the center of the screen
so that if you needed to just if you
came around a corner and there was
somebody standing right there
you could kind of just swing on them and
hopefully get a body shot and then maybe
a beat down with a sniper rifle
yeah which was actually a little too
easy to do in d1
um if you ask me but as far as what
they've changed with the scopes
yes uh i think the biggest problem
i don't actually see a problem with it i
think that
i think it actually makes sense that
longer range uh
scopes have more uh auto aim
the problem i see with it is i i think
teddy said
is the or he said is the maps
there is not really anything that has
great sniper lanes i mean there's a few
but the maps just aren't laid out like
that
and i don't know if it was they just had
it in mind in d1
the whole perspective of d2 is so much
different than d1
uh i mean even even the same maps that
they've brought back
there's just a different uh scope to it
i don't know exactly what it is maybe
it's just the difference between console
and i've been playing on pc for so long
but um but yeah i don't know
if it's gonna i don't know if it's gonna
solve the
i think it's gonna maybe cause more
problems uh
than they think it's solving uh and i
don't know what it does to sniper rifles
overall
in pve in in pve or excuse me in pvp in
pve uh
i mean i can't really even think of too
many scenarios other than like
scourge of the past or uh guarding a
salvation where you use a sniper for
anything
right so yeah
i'm sorry although i thought those were
good sorry i thought those were good
because you did it you know the way you
use them in those particular
you know situations but not enough of it
yeah i mean i make it quick because
we got a lot of other subcategories you
know i'm with e i'm a little
disappointed
that we didn't get any pve adjustment
that was my main takeaway from this
because
you know snipers are not in a good place
in my opinion in pve
especially legendaries you know i'm
saying so that disappointed me i
understand this pvp change um
let's be real you know if you want to
use you know snipers and pvp you want
that that low
you know that low scope you know you
want to be able to see everything and it
it
i understand that trade-off for making
the aim assist
you know saying affect it there um you
know
it's i agree i agree with teddy like
flinch was not discussed at all so
i'm like okay you know what i'm saying
so yeah like this
this was really light i was a little
disappointed i thought we would get more
with snipers so i guess
to clarify the amos's reduction on low
zoom scopes is technically
a implicit nerf because most people use
the low zone
zoom obviously yeah so that that could
solve the problem of the aiming at the
body getting flinched
hitting the headshot right um i don't
think it will but
i i you know
just an interesting observation that i
made and nobody does this
um but i did it one day
has anybody actually ever used the
whisper of the worm in pvp
i used to way back i've probably tried
it when it was vibrating for
entertainment value
it was actually pretty good back then it
was it still is
and actually it's like my go-to when i'm
playing gambit
because when you go when you invade if
you have heavy with whisper it's it's
sort of a double
because it does do fairly good damage to
bosses
um not the best but it's okay especially
if you're like
you're using a well or you have a bubble
or something you get some sort of damage
buff
um but if you invade that thing is like
you just get
near them and they are gone and it's so
hard too
that like you can finish them off pretty
quick and they're already taking a
little bit of damage
and at that and it in those maps i
actually think gambit is actually more
tailored to sniping
when you're invading than the actual
like crucible maps in some ways
because there's just such a bigger scale
to them and you can sort of hide off in
a corner and when you come in nobody
knows exactly where you are
so i occasionally would take it into uh
just regular crucible
and you don't get that much opportunity
to use it because you have to pick up
the heavy ammo but
when you do i would always get three
kills with it
very easily and that has a very deep
scope on it
yes very much so like that's a very long
range scope and i actually found it
fairly easy to use
yeah so i don't know no i agree like i
said time's going to tell
you know based on when we get in the
sandbox and play with it but you know
we'll see
what else we got uh cognito's gonna be
just tickled
on this one auto rifles 600 rpms we gave
them a buff
when season of the worthy were pulling
that back a little bit
damage per bullet is reduced from
currently 15.75
down to 14.25 before the buff it was
13.7
the other auto rifles are going to be
about the same so this
it was buffed by two bullet two
damage per bullet and now it's brought
down by one and a half
[Music]
just throw those things in the dirt in
the bushes i don't hate autumn oh you
think they should no go ahead i don't
you can't
lie come on you are not a fan i don't
hate them i just
feel they should have their place i just
feel with
this in the closet or the bushes
remember just listening so i don't know
listen man you know it's still gonna be
good it's still gonna be decent but you
know look
it was a fun run and i'm glad it's being
peeled back like that
at the end of the day i always feel my
only beef with autos is just as far as
the skill
as far as using another weapon i feel
it's easy to just
hold down on the button and just point
in the general direction
and get your kills and that you know
bothered me slightly yes
that it was ruling the meta now in your
defense e
they have it all those haven't had time
to shine
for a while so i let it go my main
issue was the damn years yes so i i
agree i
feel for your auto lovers this was your
run you had a good you know season and a
half or whatever it's been
to rock out and you know what no no and
my issue is
was hard light like i really didn't like
when the harlot
i knew what was going to happen with
that damn gun and the ricochet and the
no drop
off and that bothered me so it was
really my vitriol was
really hard light 600 i don't mind i
guess i got a good forward path i got a
good um
knowing hunger roll my summoner is beast
like
600 if i go i feel decent to use them
now you know every once in a while
now the thing is going to be with this
pullback
how does that now meet with hand cannons
i'm
very curious now with the hierarchy
especially you know with with this um
the damage per bullet so we get to see
the time to kill how much it adjusts i
guess the other piece is there's a lot
of auto rifle these are the auto rifles
that are used and they're bringing them
down
but it's not like the others get a lot
of use right
the slow the aggressive auto rifles
those don't get a whole lot to make them
any better than they already are which
they're not getting used it's not like
hey
600's are really good but i can still
like go toe to toe with other auto
rifles
the others ones aren't great so just the
fact that they brought this one down but
they untouched the others
mm-hmm i guess we'll have to see it but
i don't expect is it i know four fifties
does it go down to even slower than four
fifties for autos like
there's a three twenty yeah three twenty
three sixty three sixty yeah
like what's the cerberus is that a 320
oh that's
i damn looked at the video today i can't
even tell you 450 maybe i think
i think that's a 450. i think it's lower
i think it's a 300 i can't remember
exactly it's weird
yeah but either way those slow auto
rifles
i feel like you're just like shooting
through molasses those do not
don't feel great now again i don't know
where they fall in the range category i
haven't done that type of testing or
anything
but again that's one of those where yeah
they're bringing this one down but
there's a lot of other pieces that
aren't used which ties
very well in the next category scouts
have a reasonable time to kill
and can't be adjusted too much without
making them dominate the battlefield so
we're making them a little easier to use
increased how much each point of aim
assists that widens the aim assist cone
and at maximum the aim assist cone is
now 15 percent wider
i'd like to point out the part of the
sentence that says and i quote
can't be adjusted too much without
making them dominate
the battle point of contention
[Laughter]
sky rifles are my favorite archetype in
pve
i don't like them in pvp but much like
auto rifles in d1
they have basically been the brunt of
every patch note reveal
because it's like oh they're too good we
can't change them like just
separate the two things this is it's
such a big problem that they have
um and on on the one hand i sort of
understand the
distain or dislike of like someone
standing at the back of the map
and picking you off and you there's no
counterplay to that if you're not if
you're not also using a scout rifle
right and
i think that's kind of where their
mindset is at
when it comes to these guns but again
pve scout rifles suffer for this
and i i just i just want them to be good
yeah no i agree with you bro i mean
that that line irritated me well i mean
the fact that there's
i mean you said but it's there's also
like no pve mentioned
at all i get like i haven't heard
fallout like i listen to a lot of
people's different videos he was like
hey if you know scout's got a buff of
like 20 damage everyone would sit back
and do this back and forth and you need
like back and forth
if they were too strong so i get in
crucible i was like you know i didn't
think about it that way
i could see maybe but some of its map
design some of it's
there's a lot of issues but in pve yeah
i don't know of a soul that uses those
things in pve and they need a buff in
there like no other
because like a pulse rifle
always feels like it does more damage
feels better the perks go
scout rifle i mean you had something
like uh
what is the what was the pursuit
pinnacle randy's well that was one that
was a faster one what was this the
explosive one with uh dragonfly um
oxygen
oxygen like they've been scouting never
ever ever and like still there's no buff
in pve
and like maybe they don't want people
sitting in the back of a map and then
i'm like
it's i don't know the no pvp buff to
this at all again is why i said at the
start is this a crucible or is this a
like sandbox this is
100 crucible because scout rifles need
love in pvp
everybody's been saying it zero yeah so
i think a lot of this
boils down to and i think i've talked
about this before publicly if i haven't
though i'm gonna explain myself
um this a lot of this goes down to like
their
control of the perception of destiny so
what was the thing in destiny 1 that
people constantly complained about oh
you sit in the back of the map
in pve and you scout rifle and
icebreaker everything from a distance
nightfalls especially but that's because
the content was so
i don't use the word unfair but just
kind of obnoxiously difficult that
you were forced to just sit as far away
as possible and
and kill things from distance and for
the most part their pve design has like
done a pretty good job of like moving
away from that perception but i think
they're so afraid
of allowing sky rifles to be good for
that reason because
you know say they buff sky rifles in pve
for this for this upcoming raid
and this raid has two and let's say two
encounters hypothetically
uh that you could sit really far away
and just pick the boss off or pick the
encounter off
that that looks boring on stream and
that perception is really bad and so i
think they definitely are fully aware of
this
and how they approach this problem it's
the same thing crucible like remember
how much we complained in year one
of jesse two about like oh i'm just
getting picked off by mida from a
distance and there's no counter play
and and they're so careful in
controlling that that i
i feel like this archetype specifically
this gun is is
it's that it's that reflection of that
philosophy yeah
i i the only point before i get the
screen the only problem i want to get is
that um
i feel so bad for scouts because again
pve especially
right my thing is if they're not gonna
like if they
were gonna introduce a whole new line of
scouts right because a lot of stuff
being sunset the only thing
we know night watch is coming forward
for the most part like can we
do that archetype better have the most
damage
increasing perks going like you know
what i'm saying to counter that you know
what i'm saying
they got to do something because that
that part the part that first i was
playing pvp this week
and what was i i forgot what i was using
i think i was using oh i'm using cold
denial right which is a great
hard-hitting um pulse i got a god roll
on it right now
it's beast and i'm playing distance how
in theory in my mind how i should be
playing with a scout
right that distance whatever impulse
it's doing it's in cold enough
i'm out dueling people it's go it's
beautiful
and then i was fighting a guy i was
playing breakthrough whatever stupid
thing they required me to play this week
i was playing a guy and what's the
what's the new kinetic
ball a slab something slab
hungering is it oh shout out to talking
about yeah the big giant
tablecloth like the big table yeah i was
in
a long distance shootout with a guy who
had this boat and i was like part of me
is like yo that's impressive
that bulls can compete at that range
right those are good
but they make scouts useless and i'm
like this is effective but
scouts can't get no love like it just it
it
boggles me that hunger and sl whispering
slight that's right
yeah it's like oh wow i didn't even know
that that they
they had that kind of a play like that
that level of effect and to me that's a
skill up so it's like
man scouts man like they really need
something man
i get it teddy you're making fantastic
points as to why they won't do it
and i get it but it you've killed an
entire archetype guys like
no one's using these who's using them
even randy's for a minute was hot but
it's like
that's my minimum control bounty gun
that's what that is
no i i guess in their defense this
typically when they do these preview
swabs they don't actually give us all
the info
even within the things that they are
revealing yeah uh and
the numbers that they're giving us for a
lot of these guns are strictly pvp
numbers so
my guess is there are pve changes they
just haven't talked about it yet
yeah um or they'll probably save it for
the patch notes but
it is a little like why didn't you
you're already giving us the sandbox
update just throw it all in there like
the number's already set in stone like
you've already you've already gotten to
that point so
it's another case of like they're
withholding information presumably i
don't know for sure
i'm assuming but uh it's just it's
annoying
it's my favorite gun just make them good
for once
i mean i've used a bow in every dungeon
for some
thing or another and literally if i can
use a bow
theoretically a scout should also be
functional in that same place
not quite as giant of a magazine still
hits pretty hard from range pretty
accurate for the single shots that i
need
but like i feel like a scout rifle needs
to three tap a red bar and i'm like
why why what in what no
so like that's yeah like hopefully
there's more of these patchy notes i
guess that's like maybe the silver
lining we'll get
but believe me the next one's gonna make
it even better but scream you got any
thoughts about scouts and we pretty much
hammer that home
um my only thing that i would add is
like
uh i played uh in the beginning of d2
when mida was mighty
meta yeah um might have been
actually yeah the mighty meta um the
thing that
i always found that was sort of unfair
about it um
was that one it was very hard to miss a
headshot
right you know like you you could it was
it was very easy to find the
precision point and just pop pop pop pop
pop they were dead
it was so fast you know and they also
had the intrinsic perk that would
uh what would that do it would sort of
it would
stagger them a bit yeah yeah yeah
which they removed from the gun one and
they brought it back into two
yes good point about that so i always
kind of thought that
scouts um sort of like hand cannons in a
way
there needs to be more of a div and i
think you know i don't know if this is a
specific
comment for scouts or just in general
i always thought that there needs to be
a bigger divide between
precision damage and non-precision
damage
if i hit you in the head halo yes
continue i always found that it was
either like
it was either too easy to hit the head
or it didn't matter
and so it needs to be like if i think
scouts would do great
if at range like you said it was the
weapon
because it was if you hit somebody in
the head
with a scout rifle you're probably gonna
you know
and it's a heavy enough scout rifle um
you're gonna three tap them
and and that should be a legitimate play
style if you miss one
you're you know you have it there's
you're probably hung out to dry a little
bit
yeah so i i don't know if i really have
too much to say about it um because i
never really use scout rifles all that
much i just used mida a ton
at the beginning of the game because
that's really all you could use at
certain points i mean if you wanted to
be a certain level of competitive
at one point i played in this ridiculous
like
monster rock star energy like crucible
thing and it was like whoever could just
play the most crucible matches and you
had to just require points
and there wasn't one person who was in
the top ten
that wasn't using uh mida and uriel's
gift at the top
facts that was no good vanilla
right exactly and the reason was is
because
at range the mida picked up head it
picked up a head shot it was very hard
to miss a head shot
it should have been harder to miss a
head shot but then
when it became harder to admit to to hit
a head shot
scouts were no longer good right so it
was like we need to kind of go back to
the level of damage they did then
but just make it more difficult make the
aim assist bring the amuses down
oh yeah right bring the aim assist down
and make them
do more damage to precision precision
damage
yeah well next one's going to be a fun
topic
rocket launchers these heavy weapons
currently
i don't even have to finish it i don't
even have to finish it if you guys are
watching video by the way for one
shout out to all of you guys that do
catch our podcast in audio
thank you guys uh the numbers keep
growing out there thank you guys very
much for that one
but if you're listening on audio uh i
can't exactly tell you how far we're in
we're about two hours probably into the
show itself
go see what teddy just did when i said
rocket launchers cause it's worth every
penny to watch it
classic these heavy weapons currently
have very low reserves
so we're adjusting that we're expect to
take another look at rocket launchers in
a future
season they increased reserves by one or
two
depending on the inventory stat this is
all rocket launchers needed right
that's it man that was the answer that
was the answer man i think problem's off
yeah so they're good okay we're moving
down we'll just go to the gym
teddy you got honors on this one you
pulled the headphones
off let's go
three in the tube just bring
[Music]
you destroyed cluster bomb rockets
because of riven
reach which people were only using them
for that i guess you could argue callous
in your one too but yeah that's just
because the bomb rockets are just good
then nobody was using them grenade
launchers effectively
are just a better version of them with
more ammo and i don't have to reload
constantly
yes and rockets were
good because auto reloading was a
problem not auto reloading holster but
like
barricade and riffs that got destroyed
last year
so yeah i don't see why
we can't have two rockets in the tube
especially with the damage
and i think there's some exceptions to
this like ward cliff coil obviously
you can't have i mean that's just it's a
special rocket launcher but like right
what's what's the what's the gambit one
i um the one that drifter gives you
that's my baby i know you're talking
about them
yeah that's my baby why can't that have
two in the tube yeah
what's like what's the problem exactly
the problem i mean
reserve reserve increase that's a good
thing okay cool but like
but there's more issues that these
that that archive has um
and especially because the heavy slot is
such a contentious slot like i'm only
going to put on what
gives me the for pve because of those
dps and rockets just don't
cut it in any way because grenade
launchers are just a better version of
rockets
uh yeah so no let me jump in right now
because
you got me the blood's boiling i'm with
you bro like it's it look
does reserve help yes it does suck what
you know when you only could
carry five or six or whatever the number
is at a time
you know i get it but like yeah right
listen i i i i it caracas in that weird
punishment zone that scouts are in right
it's like we know the history of these
weapons and they
don't they they they're putting their
foot down they don't want us
doing that with rocket launchers sitting
back and loading but
can we get two in the tube if the damage
is not going to be effective
can we get 202 the second thing this is
my biggest problem with rocket launchers
i don't see a lot of people talk about
cluster bombs is literally the only
effective role
yeah why aren't there any other perks
that are even appealing over cluster
bombs
like snapshot on your rocket like why is
that even a thing
like there's some dumb perks that
shouldn't even be
in the perk tree for rockets and i'm
just like
hip fire grip on a sniper rifle i think
wins the cake there but
that one that was pretty good no i'm
totally with you on this one just
because yeah rocket launchers like we
had
i can't remember the one that looks like
a world war ii airplane
a dragon spread dragons like brown maybe
i'm on the ground
we could do like i mean come on rocket
launchers you could have so much fun
with like hey avoid
and this is where i wish actually energy
weapons of any type had an effect to
them
avoid rocket launcher black hole arc
rocket launcher lightning storm like
you could have fun with rocket launchers
and make them unique in that way at
least to give them something but
yeah the whole biggest thing is why
they're not used in pve as you said
it's dps like you shoot one out it
doesn't do that much damage has the
travel time you're like hold on let me
set it down let me
have my lunch first okay i'm done with
my lunch let me pick it back up take the
shell out put the other one back
in okay i'm ready to fire again oh you
went through 50 shots of every other gun
yeah but in the entire hit that hard for
that for that that's my point like if
it's going to be like that
in a pve boss it should hit that thing
for like 200 000 damage because it takes
six years to use
one rocket go you know what they sneaky
i don't know teddy on screen let me know
if y'all messed with this one they
sneaky you know what they did
they kind of brought rockets back in a
test scenario have any of you guys use
that one
that that mod godslayer warheads
use that mod god slay warheads
it takes about four f five energy in
your solar i believe it's a dawn mod or
i mean an arrival
i think it buffed at some right bro
shout out to the code in the chat
if you use two tail fox or any like
really
like i have usually the ones with
cluster bombs is kind of glitch so don't
do something with cluster bomb
but use two tail fox and that mod
rockets hit like d1 rockets and i'm like
ah i see what y'all doing y'all slick
you know say they don't want it
to be what it was and the only time you
get is if you put on that mod that's the
only thing i would say but
in in in general back i'll give it back
to you e my main issue is those
damn perks man look there's no perk
diversity
there's no firing line all even linear's
got cool
little things like fire engineers so
don't give up
we're getting to that i shouldn't yeah
you're right but like
every other archetype has like more perk
diversity that's
effective and it's like this one class
has not gotten a rework and i'm like
this is the answer more reserves but
i digress continues continuing no that's
mostly all i got is i mean
everybody is like hey rocket launchers
don't get that much use and as you're
saying there may be one challenge with
light mod that could potentially if you
get the double triple stack it actually
has a function of like one rocket where
you get to use it
what happens with the second rocket you
fire is it all of them is it what i'm
asking
you mm-hmm when you have that charge
with light like
perk is it just one rocket and then it
uses all right so basically how it works
is yeah so
you the minute you acquire charge from
light
it's basically turning it into a d1 that
one shot
is going to turn it into right so let's
say you have four charges so basically
you're going to have to stack
you you run like a supercharged mod so
you can have more charge with lights
and then each tr it's called godslayer
warheads
each one of those that you shoot it hits
like a truck you'll
melt bosses it is really effective in
how i feel like
rockets should be but they want you to
use that with like death bringer or ward
cliff coil
or something like that it's still
glitchy
with specialized rock it's like death
breaks
okay cool yeah the fun stuff no but
like you want to do something cool no no
no no take something boring the only one
that's fun
is two-tailed fox i've used that
effectively i think
shout out i may be cool guy who has a
video it's a couple maybe one of two
content creators i've seen with a video
with it
because i thought i was like oh wait a
minute this is a rocket mod
for season of arrivals and i was like
all right let me try it
i was it's very effective you know what
i'm saying but yeah scream i don't know
if you've messed with it a little bit
if you've seen it but it's pretty fun
the only rocket launcher i ever ever use
i think it's deathbringer
the one that
yeah that's the only one that i ever
found to be
um effective in any way just because you
could
hide different places and if you were
good enough you could sort of send that
thing out and then
detonate it and then everything else
would track to whatever you were doing
um or where you were trying to kill
other than that yeah i i think that
rockets need to serve the place that
swords do right now
um i think swords are
yeah they're a little i mean they're
getting a debuff
going into beyond light which i think is
is needed i think the falling guillotine
has just become too much of a thing
like i mean i use it all the time
because it's just oh it's such a thing
yeah um i think yeah two in the chamber
would be very good um
or maybe at least like a some i mean
is there a a fast reload mod that i'm
just
blanking on that you can put on there
that like increases
i mean you're looking at like rally
barricade or lunafection boots but i
mean there's no specific mod that makes
those things go much better than they
are
yeah you probably master one with reload
speed and never feel it
so maybe if they had something more
focused towards that
you know rather than i think two in the
chamber would be
would be the best though the best
solution short term wasn't
well d2 launched with only one in every
chamber but you
got two rockets in pvp right when you
picked it up okay
uh you if you picked it up yeah you got
two rockets yeah yeah
so we were thrilled and ecstatic about
rocket launchers
[Laughter]
the reserves that was the key that
answered
all the fans demands that's it they also
have some general
surgical general the following list of
surgical changes i'm like okay that's
contradictory but
uh for select weapons based on player
feedback
perks outlaw they buffed it from a
reload stat bonus of plus 50 to plus 75
so those reload perks are still good and
better in case you were wondering
merciless i forgot this existed and just
read this honestly
increased inventory this is the reserve
ammo
from 36 to 55 and that's the stat not
the number of shots so however that
translates
you have more merciless shots in reserve
it's probably like one more full eight
clip i'm guessing
yeah i would assume how that one goats
too
anybody thrilled about merciless anybody
thrilled about any fusion rifle
i did listen to datto's video shout out
to him and he literally was like
fusion rifles fusion rifles guys anybody
like does anybody use one for much right
linear fusions what's going on
why why are we not talking okay
oh yeah shout out to screen that's my
bastion vote brother talk about it okay
unique in pvp that's the only one
is just that's like the gun that destiny
wish they didn't make
i mean that thing is broken more things
i i actually think fusion rifles are
um i've always liked fusion rifles even
from d1
it was always in d1 they were almost a
little too easy earlier playing c
the linear fusion rifle thing um
i think they just need to lower the auto
aim on the exotic linear fusion right
what's that one arbalest
that thing is just yeah it needs a
bring down that auto aim just a little
bit um yeah i hear that thing on control
but then again yeah if you don't hit a
head shot with them they're useless
though that's the thing it's like if you
don't hit a head shot with a linear
future rifle you might as well just
you know wave a white flag and say kill
me
i think the um the bastion is
very very unique
and i love the bastion it's like i don't
know if i use the bastion so much
because i literally just
on pc against mouse and keyboard guys
who are hacking i just have
no chance other than to just try to get
in
somewhat of a range and just kind
i'm not i'm not a good shotgun guy um
so they were always kind of that middle
ground for me
and i having played a lot of like halo 4
like the rail gun is essentially a
fusion rifle and
yeah d2 or d1 um
but as far they're just getting more
ammo is that
that was it that one is getting more
important one more
oh okay just merciless no there's like i
mean and that's kind of thing is like do
they have a place in pve
again this is a crucible like situat
like i don't think they don't
have place in pve that's yeah that's the
big question like
there's no damage buff to be like hey
you've got some big guy running at you
are you going to pull out a fusion rifle
you may as well just set that down and
just lay down like yeah
fusion rifles don't do much in the pce
the only one that has a place in pve
is the telesto and that was because of
several things that you could just
different things you could break in the
game with it um
you know i mean even even paired with
other exotics like
um was it worm god's caress the
gauntlets for the titan
yep that the one on the ground breaking
stuff yeah you just blow up the nodes
and get the buff and then you could just
throw a
little hammer at something and do like
600k damage you know one shot
i loved it when that was a thing i mean
you know but is it a good thing no
so yeah i think i wish they had a yeah i
wish they had like a you
like an actual like purpose and it might
just be
like give them give some encounter like
eat maybe a
a a dungeon or a specific nightfall
that like a fusion rifle having a fusion
rifle
just is tops even just one even if it
was just one i think that would go a
long way
yeah let me shout out to gordon gartrell
i love the name that's a great cosby
show reference
um yeah preach brother um loaded
question that was
my baby yeah loaded question it hit like
a truck it had
extra um you know that charge up thing
and it's being the sunset too yeah
yeah and that's going to be sunset so we
got no you know i'm with you bro like
joe tune yeah fusions man they need
something
legendary fusions not so much another
legendary
mountaintop we've had a ton of feedback
that mountaintop feels a bit over the
top and crucible
really you don't say
this pinnacle weapon has had ample time
to shine
they are at least owning that one sorry
for the very very thick opinion here
uh so we're taking it down a notch
specific pain points
one shot body shot with infinite range
that's not a problem
quick and easy cleanup of wounded
guardians even around corners
deals high splash damage rewarding
players with inaccuracy
perfect in air accuracy those are two
separate things by the way that's in
air accuracy versus inaccuracy that's
not confusing
allows airborne guardians to rain down
death and there's not much guardians can
do
to respond here's the changes all i want
from you guys is a quick
yay or a nay if you think this stuff is
enough
uh reduced splash damage by 33 increased
impact damage such that the total damage
is five percent lower than before
reduced projectile velocity multiplier
of micro missile from 1.4 to 1.2 so it's
20
faster and set at 40 faster reduced in
air accuracy
uh now significant projectile air while
in air
seven degrees of inner accuracy without
icarus grip
substantially less with icarus grip is
this enough to take it out of its reign
in literal terror it's
more this boy needs more nerf
just burning to the ground a few times
about this gun and my answer is always
deleted from the game
like it's it's got to go this is this is
a shot package in a gun
situation just i i love this gun in pve
i love it i've used this gun a lot but
it just eject this out of the game
it's still going to be a problem nobody
gets it anymore
it's it's still going to be a problem i
mean these changes are great like this
absolutely they should have done this a
long time ago but
uh like normal cruise was still going to
be prom like
like think about this scenario this has
definitely happened to you guys at some
point
you're playing pvp and you're miming on
someone
and then they put mountaintop and
gnawing hunger on and then they start
memeing on you
and like then what do you do you put
mountaintop and die hunger on it and
then just
and then it just because yeah
everyone's buddy hopping and shooting in
the air and then you're literally may as
well just being scorched
whatever that's called there's no
there's no skill gap involved in this
it's just point aim
denying hunger is the same well i guess
not how you kind of have to dead shots
but like still
uh yeah i just like this gun like that
that's that's what this ball's down dude
shut up whatever
teddy emotion scream where you at man
volatile
is it enough i hate that gun so much
that i refuse to even get it
i i did i got that i was like i was
almost done with it i'm just like you
know what i hate this thing
it'll be so much of a benefit to me in
in pve
but i just hate it and i think um
i mean what they're doing with it
you know i the the thing that bothers me
the most about it is that
you can snipe with it yeah the other
side of the treadmill
you can hit somebody with that thing and
like oh you're like
there's like no arc to the trajectory of
the bullet and um
it's just straight towards you like uh
you know and i just don't understand
i didn't understand exactly like why it
works so much differently
than all the other grenade launchers
like there's nothing even similar to it
really
nothing nearly as effective it sits in
that
oh sorry go ahead no no it's unique i
think for me my biggest frustration is
the counter play there's not much
counter play like
the thing that bothers me is i'll fight
you know just shout out to the hunters i
got to come for y'all right now
but i'll fight at three stacking trials
with of hunters with this thing
they're all bunny hopping around rolling
and doing it and then the thing that
pisses me off is
even like you have to now mentally
think you're gonna get hit with this
micro missile jump but the splash damage
is so
big so even if you somehow survive the
initial
shot they just switch to their auto and
clean you up and it's all like you have
no counter play and that's my main thing
shout out to datto he has a hilarious
video
about this but um yeah man i'm with you
screen i'll give it back to you but it's
just like
that's the part about it for pve
it was part of the god loadout you know
what i'm saying
we know what it was y'all you had your
anarchy you had your recluse you had
your mouth
we understand that was a thing that part
i'll miss
but pvp this was e you proud of me
i was so happy for sunset i was so happy
i was like what's the number on this
ten sec oh yeah you're out of there
you're out of there
i was so sunsetting couldn't have come
at a better time for you
and this right here hopefully is enough
but give i'll give it back to you scream
well it's just here's every trials game
that i've ever gone into
the hunter jump shoot
jump shoot look roll jump shoot roll
jump shoot it's just so annoying
and actually this is here's a here's a
question i have for you guys
because i don't have the weapon i just
never wanted to get it and
um i i think i'm correct in that it has
a hip fire reticle on it
it does get that out of there away
if you want to really change the gun get
rid of the hip fire reticle
because that is what makes it
infuriating when you can just
it's easier to hip fire with that gun
than it is to ads with
it if you had to ads to get a good
long-range shot back a point
okay you know all those other debuffs
accompanied with that
it would make it a fairly reasonable
end game weapon i mean it should be it
is an endgame you know
it is a pinnacle so you know it should
be better than
other things but um but it shouldn't
just
be better than everything it should just
be better than everything in its
category
so every you know uh
primary it's a primary um grenade
launcher i could see it
being the best of those special grenade
launchers excuse me
um but yeah get rid of the
if you got rid of the hip fire reticle
and you actually made it
somewhat skillful you know then i could
understand it but
where i don't i just didn't understand
what went into the thinking of that
i i almost feel like the guys who play
pvp at bungie just
you know if if they get a kill with
something
i don't know if they're just not that
good at pvp but it's like whatever they
get a kill with they're like this is it
they're going all the way
[Laughter]
looks like we're all binding at the
death of this weapon oh no i mean
there's a lot of people that are happy
that this thing's going
um and i think we all agree which is a
good thing
uh there's a couple of these i'm gonna
look together two points and then we
still gotta talk about trials adapted
we got a long show thank you guys over
here we got a lot to talk about we got a
lot of good opinions so it's fun um
might have multi-tool made a mini tool
the mini tool is getting it's like midas
energy making an intrinsic perk
it's going to get hip fire grip and kill
clip seems reasonable
uh sturm and drang drang is going to get
together forever that similar perk that
works with sturm
intrinsic it's going to get accurate
rounds and moving target also good
you've got arbalest that no longer
strikes shields multiple times because i
think it like
kind of hit on the entrance and exit
wound basically so
it was a little weird but its efficacy
against shield of targets has been
increased
it's still not what gotta ask you this
because this is a good i feel
[ __ ] i feel arvila should connect with
you as a solo
nightfall dungeony kind of guy oh the
work against shields
yeah like dude it never does what i
wanted it to do so and it's not going to
so i've given up so that's funny you're
giving it
i thought that that should have been the
exotic for you oh no i haven't continued
yep never never did what it was supposed
to do because it's supposed to like
not worry about shields or something i'm
like oh cool no no
uh jade rabbit armor piercing round
swapped a high caliber rounds which
fixed a bug which is fine
two things one falling guillotine
reduced heavy attack damage by 24
to bring it in line with other swords it
will continue to be slightly above
average just not to the extent that it
is
now sad faces pour one out
thoughts you have a hand that's up [ __ ]
y'all
it was a good run come on yeah it was
like
we knew yeah like come on like like like
i
i've never pro nerf but
we know damn well when you had that
final fantasy 7 sword
you know damn well you did that
relentless blade or whatever it is and
you build it up to times five and then
your world went
you know damn well we weren't supposed
to be melting this content the way we
was about to do it
bro it was fun it was fun swords were
amazing and then shout out to um
shout out to cat daddy in the chat and
addict who didn't even know
about lucid blade in conjunction with
this
lucid blade on top of the already
destructive nature of this sword is it's
you will solo content it is so crazy it
is
it is insane so look for all one for the
homie i was like swords are still i
think going to be
lightning sword is still pretty good
they're actually in a decent space where
they like the risk versus award versus
the proximity and stop mechanics
that's a whole podcast in itself um
but swords still hit pretty hard which
is good yeah this was
just beyond god tier like s plus plus
plus here
now it's just probably gonna be like s
like this is still gonna be like one of
the best swords no question
if you still got your whirlwind
relentless strikes keep it
still gonna be one of the best swords to
use it's just not gonna be like
holy hell there's nothing else i want in
my pve heavy slot
gonna bring it down a bit now the last
one before we get to trial's adept stuff
ruinous effigy before i even say what
happened to this gun
did anybody think anything needed to
happen to this weapon
yes oh spicy
well do you talk because you might be
the only one
what glitch you found out with this gun
that you now you mad let me hear
break it down constant invisibility
grabbing the orb and running through any
nightfall or deal at 1100
by yourself you can do it you don't need
anything else
you can do this this is a bungee
protection play of co
of of of content i think that's why
they're doing it specifically as people
were able to do that
you could i mean you can keep your
invisibility on a hunter if you
build the right the right perk tree the
right perk builder excuse me the right
mod build um you can you can
get invisibility dodge get it right back
pick up the orb and just continue that
i mean you'll never run out of it and
it's just not happening
with the chat he said you'll be training
on just continue
[Laughter]
citizens he's upset
for me it's like you got to realize i i
say this with a gran
take it with a grain of salt in my
opinion because i love all these things
like when i find one of these it's like
a gem
it's like oh great this is this is it
yes
okay it's like sin get in here get your
hunter
we're gonna two-man this uh but uh
yeah i think that's specifically that
one reason is why they're they're
changing it
question do you think because this is a
theory of mine before we move on
do you think they have some upcoming
content
that they realize the efficiency of this
weapon
wouldn't be too op for the encounter
that i always
feel when you get these random what the
f
nerfs like the sleeper ricochet which we
still don't even know what was
for still don't know why do you
teddy i'm pretty convinced that that
nerf was done
because datto made a video where he
showed that you could bounce
sleeper off the uh the shield
of uh what's the boss from either um
argos so when is shields down once you
completed the mechanic there was like
the little like corner
that the shield was part of the the
geometry was still there and you could
bounce it off that with a
marginally okay success rate and it
would do
a little bit more damage so i'm
convinced that they saw that video and
we're like
oh crap someone's going to find out how
to like melt some boston that supposed
to melt and then they nerfed it
well there's like a third nerf i think
to the gun yeah which is planted it's
gravestone so yeah
that's my theory i don't know if that
actually happened but i like to think
that's what happened
i mean it makes sense like i mean that's
kind of thing they said now the one like
reduced the damage of the aerial melee
attack
you jump in the air and you swing the
orb i'm like
who thought that was too strong yeah
like who's jumping up in the air
smacking stuff with the orb
now they significantly reduced the
damage of the drain effect on an enemy
combatants
that's where i think you're on to
something there's like a horde of
enemies two people with ruin of
effigies just like melting hordes of
enemies as they walk forward and they
clear an entire like
army that's coming at you and it's like
two balls could do that and you're like
that may be a bit of an issue the shield
may be there
yeah while staying completely invisible
and not taking any aggro from anything
and there's a build you can do with a
warlock um i can't remember exactly
uh it's i think it's middle tree void
um or no bottom tree void whatever gives
you
yeah the one that has is that the one
that has the ability
where whenever you do void damage you
get some of your health back i'm trying
to remember exactly
but that works with the ruinous epigene
so you could just
burn that thing forever and like even
when you would get low even when you'd
have the orb and it would start to do
damage to you
you could get your health back if there
was enough enemies around you
right there was a way you could break
the whole um the whole
this is for hunters and like one
encounter in beyond light
it's just one of those like rudeness
effigy was like you went through you
shot all the eyes i know even cognito
you got done doing the whole like series
of shooting guys recently and you're
like
hey the gun's kind of cool but i never
hear anything about it being broken
you're like
why and it's some weird ass thing that
we don't even know anything about
basically
they saw us they saw a scream yeah they
saw scream coming
they said coming they know about you
yeah i could see the meeting now there
were like screams using this gun we got
another
yeah this man finds out and i saw that
weapon
when i saw that weapon in like the
preview i was like oh this is gonna be
so broken i'm like
to see what people do with this it's
like the thing that's coming
i i don't know how it'll maybe maybe
they realize this will pair with this
weirdly too but whatever
um i think it's hunters are getting that
ability to throw their grenade against
the wall and it
shoots out the spikes that you can oh
everybody everybody gets all the
grenades oh everybody's getting that
that's i'm side note
what that is going to be broken day one
oh yeah that is like the first thing i'm
looking at that's going to break
so many things in the game all the old
stuff
broken with that i don't know maybe they
figured out those two things in
combination were just not good
fair enough you're on it man i always
think these are
those are those random rare preemptive
nerves where we scratch our heads but
guys like scream you know they gotta try
to stay ahead of you as best they can
[Laughter]
all right so the final thing we got to
talk about it's a long show but we
definitely have to talk about this one
adept and that's literally all they say
it's literally a depth in parentheses
because that's what it's going to say on
the gun
so i'm going to read this out and then
there's two main pieces to talk about
how what the actual adapt weapons do and
when
and how you're going to be able to get
said weapons
so trying to read this quickly but i
want to cover it all verbatim so i don't
skip anything
get it brother so before we let our
friends on the development team go we
have a few more details concerning
weapons to share with you a few months
back we announced the return of adept
weapons to the trials experience
today we will be spending some time
getting you reacquainted with these
tools of destruction
and how we're laying the groundwork for
future adept weaponry which they said
they may be coming to nightfalls later
in case you guys aren't aware
while these weapons are similar to the
name in to the depths of destiny 1
there are some added elements to embrace
the weapon systems of
destiny 2. with that we pass the mic
back to our development team
beginning in beginning and beyond light
all existing trials weapons will have
adept versions so there's going to be
launching with beyond light
our intent is for all new trials weapons
to have an adept version in the future
with their infusion caps matching the
season they were introduced in
for our first round of adepts which i'm
going to put a giant asterisk so this is
their test phase because it's short
their infusion caps will be set to that
of season of the worthy
and in case you don't know what that
implies the adept weapons that you can
get
in beyond light will last for season 12
which is the
like beyond light season and season 13
and that is it
you get it for two seasons not four so
they will last half as long
additionally we will be introducing
adept weapon mods into the sandbox and
beyond light which can only be applied
to adept weaponry
here's how adept weapons differ from the
base weapons master working in adept
weapon grants additional stats
plus 10 for the primary stat so if it's
range you get plused into range
but also gives plus three for the
alternate stats which i'm guessing is
the other master working alternate stats
that you can have
i'll ask you guys here in a second adept
weapons can use either a standard weapon
mod
take barrier extended mag whatever or a
new adept weapon mod earned when going
flawless
though the adept mods do come from the
flawless chest so do the adept weapons
as well
a unique adept shader has been made for
these weapons note these shaders are not
awarded as consumable
and so they're the only weapons that can
look this way
adept weapon mods come in two varieties
weapon stat boosts
which each will grant a plus into a
particular stat in the same way
masterwork does
so if you have a weapon that has plus 10
mastwork
you can also take an adept mod and plus
and put another plus 10
on that as well uh some versions of
these existing mods grant an improved
bonus but with a downside
adept mag for example is plus 40 to the
magazine stat but minus 20 to handling
versus say backup mag which is a general
mod for everybody it's plus 30 to the
stat
final piece is acquisition to earn adept
weapons in an and weapon mods players
must complete a flawless trials passage
and open the flawless chest at the
lighthouse
each week a def a different adept mod
can drop from the flawless chest
adept weapon mods will be on a weekly
rotation so a given mod may not make its
appearance until later in the season
the mod is unlocked for use uh on owned
depth weapons when acquired so if you
have six adept weapons and you get the
mod you can use it on any of them
adept weapons will be available from the
flawless chest on a bi-weekly basis
alternating with armor drops the first
weapon acquired on a given week is a
pinnacle drop
adept weapons will be on a set rotation
so players may continue to earn
alternate roles on a specific dead depth
weapons
when completing flawless passages
throughout a given weekend
i'm trying to see if there's anything
important down in the bottom
as you can see for those who reach the
lighthouse your loot is about to get
more spicy while adaptive rewards are
coming first
we also have a trials armor refresh
planned for a future season
after the stardust has settled from
beyond light
that pretty much sums up adept weapons
for the information so the first one is
what do you guys think about the actual
adept weapons
functionality like what is gonna set
them apart
uh when you go and you get that adept
weapon from the chest is it going to be
worth it to
to you guys do you guys think this makes
them worth the
the seven flawless wins come on trials
gang talk to me
uh go go ahead uh screamer or
cognito um i'll scream go i think
i think it's gonna really come down to
how they how it plays how it feels
i mean i think because we've
there's been things like this in the
past right like and
it all depends on at the end of the day
is this weapon
really that much feel that much better
than everything else because there's
some times where like
you know i mean think about how many
weapons in the game right now
there are there have been in the past
where you could go and get like
a white weapon from the beginning of the
game
and it was still as um usable
in and crucible as other things i mean
like what was it the pharah
i used to use that thing forever and it
just because it felt good it when you
shot it the way it sounded
the way it handled it all felt good and
i think you know i honestly think that
this is good because it sounds like it's
they're really trying to make trials
feel
worth it and
but but i don't really know enough
about playing with these weapons where
it's it's going to be
can these weapons that you earn in
trials be taken into normal crucible
and you feel like a god with them like
that's i think the goal
right i don't i i won't know if that's
the case until
you actually do it i hope that's the
case it sounds like that's the case
um it certainly sounds like that's what
they they want to be the case
but i won't know until i play with one
of these weapons
with one of these mods equipped i like
the way that they're staggering it i
think that's sort of interesting
um and i like what they're doing with
the mods that sounds
unique enough
this was a nice surprise um
yeah i mean are we are we touching the
the the
the light level thing now or we this is
just now my initial thoughts on
light levels in there the only thing i
was going to save is like the
acquisition and timing stuff or that's
my other point
okay so yeah the light level the how
they've like their functionality their
stats like
yeah everything about the weapons i'm
just getting to the timing for a
different piece that's a point
yeah the light level thing obviously you
know what i'm saying is a time it almost
feels like a
uh a trial phase
it's half a normal anything basically
right right look
i like it you know adept weapons need to
happen
um i'm with scream we do need to see how
efficient these
buffs are actually going to be i i think
in the right hand certain roles could
really be powerful
because if you master work i'm just
thinking of something like
what is it um is this someone what
what's
that's the one we got now no yeah the
summer summer is it called seminar
forgetting the auto now what's it called
the summer yeah right okay so if i'm
going if i get a master
with a plus 10 you know and then you got
plus three on alternate stats then you
got
another mod that in a sense could be
stacked on top of that
because i'm not seeing anything where
they say you can't have these
combinations
seems like it should this this sounds
like you know
it could be good my only slight
disappointment was actually that it's
the same weapons coming back
you know so i'm like okay i don't is
there going to be a world
where the scholar is going to be super
lit
with this and that's my issue right
because
let's be real us trials guys here right
it's it's um astral horizon
it's summoner i i mean
it's all kind of yeah kind of is the
rocket launcher making you jump for joy
is diffusion making you jump out the
window
not necessary maybe a window not for joy
yeah you know so that basically
the the the weapons that have been the
meta four trials those two or three
are going to get astronomically bumped
up most likely
the only thing i would say look i like
the move only thing i will say i don't
like
and me me and you've had this
conversation is they're trying to debut
this new thing
with iron banner where it's like as far
as got one mod where it's like
oh plus 40 this but my
25 fat they're saying okay i i agree 100
if you get to the flawless chest and you
work your tail off
and i have to and i get a mod that's
like and this is the one they
listed for example backup mag no give
and take
plus 32 of magazine stat now that's not
30 bullets that's just like the stat
however it works with sad gun
a depth mag is literally say we're going
a third like 33 more magazine whatever
that is could be one bullet six
eight who knows but you're dropping 20
handling when they do these drops on
anything in this game it's like
10 or 20 you're losing 10 strength which
is a whole
like level you're losing 20 handling
that's a fifth of a gun
that gun feels a lot slower to bring out
and take out
for like what is that going to be one or
two more bullets
like that adapt mag already feels like
it's terrible in my mind
that i wish you if you want a magazine
go with backup mac because
right the give and take it doesn't feel
worth it when i see those type of things
it it deterred me from iron banner that
that when it was those guns that came
with with those guys
and whatever yeah iron this and iron
that and i was just like what stability
yeah like for me all that is going to
incentivize me is to
play the week that the mod is a flat
number even if it's a little less
where i don't have that negative impact
so much you know what i'm saying
so that's it look i do say i love the
fact that the shader camera broke down i
know it's stupid but i like that no but
i honestly i just don't think it should
be a shader they should just
intrinsically be that color
not that it's a specific shader that
comes on they should just they should be
a depth weapon should look like that
then you can share them how you want to
but because if you like
that you can't get it back right i just
like the fact that this is just [ __ ]
you talk now
i just like the fact no one can get in
there like you can't get there to set
them apart but look absolutely that's
totally fine 100
it did let's overall sound like i'm
complaining this is
in my opinion the step in the right
direction we needed the debt weapons we
needed this to go
i guess slight little disappointing
weapons it's like a little
disappointment about
that one particular mod with you know
this extreme you know variable thing
but overall yes this is i feel
good you know but again to scream's
point
is it going to make the sky lit
if i go bust out the scholar now because
i got in a depth version with plus 10
range or whatever whatever like is it
going to affect those
non-meta trials weapons in
any efficient capacity to make it now
farmable
that's the question that to me has to be
answered and i'm not
i'm not sure right now i'm leaning to
like yeah probably not but
in fairness i need to get a hold of it
and then see but like
say somebody has a summoner right now
that has a good role
it's got a ranged masterwork is it worth
that person
to go after an adept version that is
going to get them
plus three to three other stats right
and then give them an extra slot where
they could add some more stat to it
is the summoner that has say a summoner
with the plus 10 range stat because
range is pretty good on an auto rifle oh
absolutely
so if you got plus 10 say it's sitting
at 60.
does it really make that like grind to
go for that perfect stat roll or to get
that adapter weapon maybe you just need
one
but then you still have to get the
masterwork adept
you just get the adept auto rifle that
has the range masterwork
and a good stat roll and then you can
put that range mod on top of it
is that worth it and is it worth the
material grind to masterwork
all of that to order
exactly that's the issue because that's
right i was gonna say and that ties in
perfectly to what the other point is
is when you can get these things we
don't know how long these seasons are
going to be
theoretically by this it makes me feel
like it's going to be about 12 weeks or
it feels like it almost has to be
because they say adept weapons will be
available from the flawless chest on a
bi-weekly basis
if you have a 12-week season you have a
weapon
and armor weapon armor weapon armor you
alternate on weeks
say the summoner is on week 11 of season
of beyond light when you get that adept
summoner with that god roll it's going
to be usable in in-game content for
three months are you going to want to
dump the cores and everything on that
now maybe if you're playing a lot of
trials you might be swimming in coors
maybe you do it
but again as that's that test period
whatever's at the end of this upcoming
season
is going to have a very very short
lifespan and you have
weapons on every other week so
everybody's going to be like hey let's
play trials this week it's armor never
mind
hey let's pray trials this week it's
armor never mind there's gonna be this
yo-yo of like the population because
they say anything they're gonna do with
armor though
just kind of curiosity they're doing
that on a future season they didn't say
anything so the arm is literally the
same
which most people already probably have
it so those weeks when the chest has
armor in it
nobody's going to care they're going to
try to they're going to spice it up but
try to probably put a good
mod maybe maybe but those are on a
weekly basis those just rotate
so those m there might be five mods or
four if they're based on maybe some of
those stats four or five mods
those are going to be sprinkled
throughout so maybe there's a range mod
on an off week
they'll be smart to try and do that yeah
and maybe it's not a guarantee so you
got to go a couple times
i don't know uh it says that mod can
drop from the flawless chest
right so i guess that might be the thing
but the fact that the weapons
are going to be every other week say if
you want i
have saul and it's in this first week
what if you're not ready
what if you want to get ready for the
raid what if you want to do other things
and not just
go try and get a flawless card done in
trials and you have other things you
want to do and you can't
no it's a good point yeah they're
usually disabled trials
uh before the raid at least in destiny 1
and 2 they
yeah they're two didn't have trials well
it did for the first year
they'll usually disable trials uh before
they're right after
until after the raid comes out which
also said that but yeah which still
makes me wonder like how the season
dates are gonna go on this one because
if this is maybe because then we have
the big raid launching maybe this season
is longer maybe they shorten some of the
future seasons if they like condense
though
again a lot of stuff we still don't know
but the fact that it's like
likely you're going to get a probably
one chance at most of these
there's one weekend so if you want
astral horizons adept
but it's on like the ninth week or
something like that
there's three weapons in there that you
guys said you didn't even care for
rocket launcher fusion rifle scout rifle
so there's three like flawless chests
that a lot of people aren't going to be
going for
i'm not against it believe me it's like
the fact that they they're making the
flawless chest have a better carrot at
the end of the stick
means the people who are likely to get
there the better players who can go
flawless
they're getting out of that like bounty
category of the first three wins they're
getting
a little farther into their cards which
is a good thing i'm not opposed to that
the shaders a good thing mine is like
as little and again i'm not a trials
player that's totally me if i ever get
to go
like if i ever get to go play trials and
i get like maybe some really good
backpack space that i get to hop into
because it's gonna be required
and then that one time i get like say i
get a summoner but it's just like a
total trash roll
and that's like the one card that i get
i'm like
well that was that that was fun so it's
just like
it's and again the people who can grind
it out that's who this is for and i
totally get like the pvp players who are
like i'm in trials every week i'm going
to sit here and grind until i get that
good one
this is what it's for and honestly i'm
happy for them for that i just honestly
hope that like
the specific timing of things the way
some of these like give and take mods
i know this is like a trial and it's
short which is probably not a bad thing
so they can kind of take feedback
i'm just i'm hoping this is i'm hoping
this is enough for like the
you know weapon scientists that this is
actually like people are like
hey honestly these adept weapons are
pretty solid i'm hoping that's the
review when these things finally come
back after they've seen some time
daddy scream way out uh i think you guys
pretty much hit the nail on the head for
everything i wanted to say um three of
these weapons
are basically useless uh and i don't
think that
this really changes that now i'm kind of
confused on this maybe you guys can
clarify this for me
are the weapons themselves is it gonna
be like astral horizon
parentheses adept or is it just astral
horizon
with a mod slot that you can put in a
dipped mod
into it and that's actually what makes
it a depth but only that version drops
with that extra mod slot
i would assume it's parentheses of depth
that's how they used to be and even the
part of the twab is parentheses adept
so i think that kind of implies yeah
it's going to have the mod slot but i
think it's going to be like the summoner
parenthesis adept
okay and it's going to look different
and have the slot you evon just touched
on this which is
you know i go flawless the week that
summoner adept is dropping and i get an
absolutely trash roll on it
and that's and that's my run right like
you know i'm not great at pvp so
my clan mates shout out to backwards uh
carries me all the time
and so like you know that's my run for
the week and i got a bad summer but then
in my vault i have a god world summoner
but i
can't put in a dip mod on that so that
kind of you know but then also
these i i like the changes
i like the adept isn't it doesn't sound
too overpowered on paper so i think it's
kind of a fair like
chase thing to go for um i kind of
equate this to like
uh like the the super special hollow
secret rare card that you get and you
know in a pack or something of a trading
card game like you gear or magic or
pokemon
you don't you don't need the rarity bump
but you kind of want the rarity bump
and it's i mean yeah i think the
the the kind of like part that i don't
like about this is that
they're only good for presumably six
months assuming the seasons don't get
shorter
so yeah i'm mostly okay with this
okay i think it's fine the trade-off the
trade-off mods i'm not okay with but
yeah enough for your brother my face
scream i'm curious man
i give you one of my trials runners man
putting some blood and sweat tears
together in there
yeah i mean it's all going to come down
to whether or not it's
it's worth it in the end whether or not
it's worth
you know whether or not the bump that
you get from these things
obviously like you said there's not
going to be that many that are even
worth it so it's like
as far as the weapons are concerned so
it's like you know i
i really don't know i i really don't
until i'm in there until i'm doing it
until i'm playing and getting these and
seeing
how how much of an effort i have to put
in
to finally get something if it may if it
makes me
feel like i have that that edge
that i took the time because the way i
always kind of think about it is that
those sort of
uh pinnacle pve activities yeah they're
really
they're really made i mean there's the
people who can just go through
and get flawless all the time you know
but it's not they're not really made for
them
they're made for the people who get
carried by those guys
who want to get the weapon from that go
into normal crucible and feel like
they can finally compete with the normal
people
and i think that's really what's going
to make it or break it
i do think that one little weird thing
is
that sort of trade-off um
but yeah we'll see i don't really i
don't really know enough to say too much
more honestly i don't really
but yeah it's interesting um
yeah we'll have to see no yeah we got to
see you know i'm saying at the end of
the day like i said he made some good
points about the
the cadence about when he's going out
and um
you know i will say this though i mean i
could see a scenario where
you know you get a summoner role or
something
with an extra 10 you know saying and it
could get really filthy and their skill
gap
could jump you know what i'm saying
again with those particular weapons but
you know overall like you said scream we
got to see we got we got to see but
again step in the right direction don't
know how i feel about the time
gaining what he is saying like of the of
the cadence of specific mods
like shouldn't they all be kind of
available what if you're out of town for
a weekend yeah
and you just can't get that particular
gun that you want
and it's only that weak and it's like
you're kind of screwed right because
what's the rotation then it coming back
around right so
that part i'm i'm with e like part of me
is like why are they restricted
time gaining this pool for specific
things
and especially when it's a limited you
just told us now it's a limited amount
of time
we're gonna have with these weapons as
it is so they better be i would say
just based off of that they better be
really really good
they just better be you know that's
that would be the only reason that it
would make sense at that point
they're not um so far as i know they're
not
you're not able to actually still you're
not able to get
the trials chest more than once correct
per week
all weekend you can find it all week you
can farm it all weekend you can get the
drops on the chest
now your first pinnacle but yeah you can
sit there and go over and over and over
and go for the drops
oh okay but again it is you know that's
why i was like so for those who like
hey you've got your pvp gods and they're
just gonna be sitting there going
through card after card until they get
the drop they want
that's what they'll be doing but again
say that pvp gods like
i got a trip this weekend and i miss the
summoner
or astral horizon or i have solid and
they wanted that one good sniper
coming from there that's where i think
the
timing is the issue but yeah they can
farm it as much if they're here yeah
they can farm it as much as they want
yeah so i just thought about this while
you were talking about this uh
i feel like that they are intentionally
gating
the the weapons are spacing them out in
a cycle so that
the the player population of trials
stays relatively
active like some weeks obviously you'll
have
less people like if the you know the
fusion rifle rolls around or something
um but then when the shotgun comes up
everyone's gonna be playing right and so
oh yeah uh i i i almost think that this
is a very deliberate
uh choice to keep because the the player
population is a problem in trials
especially
after the first month of the season they
introduced it it was like that's it it's
done like
and even the beginning of this season
too it wasn't it wasn't great getting
the second flawless title
this season was a nightmare uh the first
season wasn't that bad
uh but this season was not that was
awful
um so i i i think they're it's
it's intentional on their part yeah i
mean it makes
it makes sense and again like the people
who will go be like okay so what are the
drops this week
like as soon as we know the drops you
could probably guess what that
population is going to look like
because there's going to be some people
wanting to farm that thing and there's
going to be quite a few people in there
that might actually be a time for the
average person
if cheating is under control is a thing
but again this will be the biggest thing
is wit you
put those really coveted weapons at the
end this is going to exacerbate the
cheating
if it's an issue to the absolute maximum
level
so if cheating is not an issue if
cheating is not an issue
you know then you're going to have a
really popular weekend the average
person might be able to get a little
higher in their car and get a little bit
more but if cheating is an issue
oh my god i don't look forward to that
yeah shout out to jeremy
in the chat um also he made a good point
like i want to know like how effective
these
debt weapons will be outside of it right
outside of trials like
can i use this in in pve content and be
effective you know i'm saying will
will they at least um open up the the
perk tree
and add additional perks that maybe
sometimes maybe these guns didn't get
so like you know again that fusion and
the scholar
like i would like to use it in other
things being it is not that great in the
pvp sandbox so
how about you throw on you know some
cool perks or some damage increasing
perks and stuff like that that weren't
there the first time
to now incentivize us to roll because
let's be honest when no
when the scholar comes up
who's really pumped that week yo seven
wins scholar
tomorrow's answers out this week let's
do it y'all ready
tomorrow this is what makes me wonder
what the
nightfall type of depths are going to be
like if we get another if we okay what's
that's a bad example i'm trying to think
if nope can't go there either i'm trying
to think of strike exclusive but half
those strikes are leaving the game
yeah if there is a strike exclusive come
on i can't actually pair one together
that's staying
take duty bound for example i know it's
leaving so you get a duty-bound auto
rifle
and now you have a adept
version of a duty-bound auto rifle right
is that going to excite me to go
grind out like grandmaster nightfalls
for this that's
if that's what these look like i mean
for pvp it's more of like a balanced
situation
where things can't be like crazy over
the top like you will break things in
pvp so
working on a little bit of range or like
for controller players maybe you want
more stability and you can get like plus
20 which will feel
but if i like if i get like plus 20 like
20 stability in
a pve situation that's not really going
to excite me that much it's not going to
excite you at all like ooh you get more
magazine space with this depth mod from
the grand master i'm like
cool three more bullets and my pulse
rifle like do what that's
again as these are kind of good you know
yeah
no no so
that's again this is kind of that test
and then the future ones are going to
come later
pve stuff i hope is pvp has to be
somewhat in control because you can't
have like hey this thing fires like 7
000 bullets a second has 200 range like
you can't do that
but in a pve sake that's the place where
i do want them to kind of get a little
broken with like grand master nightfall
stuff
so i'm hoping they can make a difference
between these two
this is a great gun in pvp and it is
going to be good there
this has very specific pve perks and i'm
hoping they can make that distinction
yeah because if it's like these types of
things for grand master
like those type of depth levels gonna be
kind of sad
i think i agree and last point i'll say
about
beating this to death i perfect where i
doubt this happens
i would love for them to do what they've
done with the season of arrival
farmable weapons where you have that
extra
perk choice so that if you farm it and
you get it and the first initial one is
not exactly what you want
but there's still a little bit of rng to
help with the second one that's like
okay you know what
subsistence and maybe this and all you
know i'm saying like just that
i love that about farming season of
arrival weapons
that makes it worthwhile because lesbian
rng can be brutal you you go to the
lighthouse
and you do trials and you come back
there with some
whack perk you got me mad you go you
don't say like you're gonna be upset
that you did that and you ain't got no
you know what i'm saying like so i i
love it almost is like a
perk rng protection and i love just
going in there like farming and ikelos
uh weapons until i get the exact you
know things that i want
that's gonna make it fumble that's gonna
make it fun but if you put this static
one roll in one chance and that's
it and you get a bad week and then oh
gotta wait for the summoner four four
weeks now or whatever it is you're not
gonna be that happy you know so
hopefully they do that too
but yeah that's mostly what i've got uh
that kind of covers the twab
we all know bounties are mostly they
seem not to be worth it is the way they
read most of your bounties will stay
intact but any boundaries tied to
specifically seasonal
specifically that's not even a word
specific seasonal activities
or content entering the dcv will be
removed on november 10th
examples include black armory gambit
prime festival of the lost any
additional bounties that grant progress
towards
infamy or valor so gambit and crucible
bounties may negatively
impact your powerful rewards related to
like leveling up your valor
leveling up your all of those things um
so our recommendation is go ahead and
claim your bounties so
while technically you could get some
experience towards your season pass with
certain ones
like i feel like zavala bounties might
be an okay thing to do
gunsmith bounties might be an okay thing
to do but there's a lot of them that
really don't do you much good
which again you can take the risk and
what it's going to help hurt or
otherwise read it carefully pick what
you want to do just be weary
falla's got to get pretty good breakdown
of like what you kind of need to go
through but it's honestly pretty
intricate to try and get a lot of
benefits from saving bounties
so if you do consider it just do your
research before you put the time in
and then don't screw yourself over in
the first week either so i have all i
wanted to say there
no actual factual well gentlemen
it has been a lot of fun but we are at a
insanely long podcast it's been three
hours
thank you guys for giving us your time
this evening um we're gonna go through
let you guys do your outros the floor
will be yours uh
scream let's get you first um
tell everybody where they can find you
what you got coming what you're going to
be doing when beyond light is coming
what they're looking forward to how many
ways can you break the game
where can they find you what are you
doing what do you got coming
well you can find me not tweeting out
any of my content on twitter at wilhelm
underscore stream
or you can find me on youtube if you i
think if you search
wilhelm scream destiny i i think i come
up now
uh i think even wilhelm scream actually
comes up i'm finally beating the actual
wilhelm stream on youtube which is
i actually got a message from the band
will help the wilhelm scream recently
and they're like who are you
because i was slightly higher than them
on youtube and i think they were a
little
excuse me a little upset about it
uh yeah you can find me there uh or
you know anywhere these guys are
producing content you'll
find a retweet from me thank you guys
for having me this was great
always brother always always a pleasure
man you already know big scream in the
building
that's what's up tweet those videos man
the videos are good
teddy ted man the legend what's going on
yeah
uh thanks for having me again guys this
is this is always awesome to
talk about destiny and you know kind of
kind of air my my grievances and salts
out a little bit
oh it's good to get it out there just
let it be don't keep that all don't keep
that all inside it's not helpful yeah i
i i mentioned this off off stream but uh
by pure chance i have now been on every
21 episodes so
yeah we can go ahead and book your next
one right now actually let's see
146.46 we'll get you
guys and i feel like it's it kind of
fits the end of the season theme because
we've always kind of
we've always around that point so it's
nice but anyway thank you guys for
having me so much it's it's always
awesome talking to wilhelm
also nice talking to you and me it's
great meeting you too teddy yes
definitely uh definitely we gotta we
gotta break some stuff together because
i have
for sure like breaking stuff yes you two
are gonna be
made in heaven um you can find me on
twitter at teasing teddy i
generally am either trolling a co-worker
or someone else
or uh occasionally posting something
meaningful and thoughtful
um and sometimes at the end of the
season usually see me posting about
destiny how i've
uh relegated too much of my life to
triumphs and
things that don't matter if you're
looking for the 100
man or you need to know what that
aspirational score is
go look at him he'll tell you what the
top number is because he's got it i i
have
i don't i don't know this is an
accomplishment or not that's like pat
myself in the back but
i have successfully reached match max
triumph score every season since season
of opulence
wow uh uh and uh i came to that
realization this season and i'm not
exactly sure if i feel good about that
or not
so uh there were there were some low
points in there uh
ultra sorrows specifically but uh 500
runs or something right
500 waves i have lost wave does not
count
wow yeah that was uh that was a fun week
but uh
anyway thank you guys we have different
definitions of fun but that's fine yeah
uh it's always always a pleasure so
absolutely well cognito what do you got
going on iron lords
podcast any awesome guest shows coming
up nothing to talk about as we get
closer and closer to just absolute
insanity right
nothing's
[Music]
before i even get into what i'm doing
again salute to scream salute you know
what i'm saying teddy man this is family
this is discord fam
always love our chats you know when we
talk in destiny we always have a good
time
it's not to scream he's always helping
people always you know even when i'm
kicking his screen but he's like come on
god you know
it'll be easy i'm sorry we didn't get
the uh catalyst for the whisper last
night i just fell right asleep but there
will be a night this week
i appreciate you bro with you you helped
out anyway you know saying with so many
stuff and teddy we always have our good
intellectual discussions late night so
salute to you man it's always
good to have you guys on and again we
got to keep the 21 streak alive
so we got to keep that going you know go
we'll see you in uh
i don't know how many weeks that is he
in like april or march or something
mm-hmm absolutely man but yeah for me
but you already know i love podcasts
every sunday 11 a.m eastern
we're gonna have a young indie developer
neil jones man he's got a game
coming out on um it's called aerial
night and it's a runner it's coming out
on playstation 5 as well as series
x so young developer man really cool
line of energy and um yeah we've been
following this journey so come check us
out a little development talk a little
fun we'll talk about these consoles we
talked about
play 65 in the wild for the first time
so we're getting to see that
you see boxes boxes are out there yes
boxes are out we understand so we will
see that
we'll talk about else what's going on in
the games industry
and uh yeah man last word chat man i was
on fire man i love the chat today
absolute pleasure this is a fun fun show
and sandbox you know i geek out so i
apologize for the length of time
i blame me my excitement level for
sandbox changes is
this is like you don't get these that i
don't get this like this is what i mean
you get them once a season that's
literally a bunch of cadence and
hopefully with all the changes you get
them more frequently maybe i
nerd out there's nothing to me more
exciting this is when i jump on
i i pull all my quote unquote what i
think the meta is going to be weapons
out the vault and then i start going
through a crucible and then just testing
these things out and seeing what's
effective so
this was for me salute to y'all fair
rocking out man for the for the three
hours because we definitely did a long
one but hey
what's going on with you man you got a
lot going on yeah uh got a couple
unboxings coming up one i got the
collector's edition sitting on the table
haven't even opened the box yet because
i do want to record that one
no i am not even remotely
big enough to be on anybody's radar for
that one i see the austin evans i see i
was like oh he got one so we gonna get
that unboxing right
the love but it is uh misplaced
rightly so so behind that green screen
there's an xbox series x right
correct yeah it's right here you just no
hold on where is it there it's right
there
can't see it's behind the curtain right
over there and i'm hiding a series s
over here in my bookshelf so
bro this is the ambassador of outriders
i don't hold anything
i've got some swag so stay tuned uh
potentially related
so uh but yeah i am an ambassador for
outrider so i'm going to be kind of
getting some contact on that one
but honestly i am dreadingly looking
forward to the week of november 9th and
10th
and 11th and 12th and 13th and
everything that that's going to do
because
i'm going to play destiny but then
godfall and demon's holes are the other
two i really want to cover
and then cyberpunk is later and i just
don't know if i'm ever going to sleep
again
so i'm going to try and cover those as
much as i can if you guys are subscribed
to the youtube channel you're probably
gonna see a lot of videos they may not
all be destiny but destiny will be
sprinkled in but it may be like
demon souls godfall destiny or some
relation thereof but i'm gonna try and
do as much as i can during that time
because
i have the full week off so you'll
probably see me crying on stream every
so often as well
but that's about all i got uh twitch
twitter youtube it's ubontis everywhere
thank you guys very much i am working
with an artist on kind of a shirt design
as well for me to try and actually get a
shirt so
cheetah kind of curious where it's gonna
look uh i wanna get it like designed
first before i even know it's going to
be there but i am working on kind of my
first shirt so
no idea the timing on that one but keep
your ears peeled as well
uh but i don't want to thank scream man
awesome to get you in here it has been a
long time coming always love it was a
perfect one for you story theories spin
foils
oh yeah and then of course teddy at the
end of the season seeing the triumph
score getting the theories about
everything both you guys amazing and of
course my co-host
sir cognito couldn't do it without you
man we always keep this train going
um for this episode guys we have gone
way too long so if you guys made it seen
in this thing i am honestly surprised
but we'll find out thank you guys who
all listen on audio if you do listen to
us on spotify itunes anything like that
please leave likes positive reviews
however that can help us out
and i think for this week i've got who i
know who we're going to go raid so stay
tuned for that one but for episode
number 125
october 23rd thank you guys very much
and it has been
the last word